Die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.
Das ist ein hartes Urteil, lieber Juwe.
Ja, Juwe ist ja eh ein eigenes Kapitel. Da könnte man eine mehrstündige Sendung allein aufzeichnen. Ich möchte auch nochmal bei Lazio reingehen. Also Lazio ist für mich wirklich herausragend. Wer hätte Napoli mit Lazio auf 1 und 2 getippt? Der darf gerne hervorkommen. Den schaue ich mir dann mal an. Also Mario hat sie gesagt, sorry. Ja, also was die Mannschaft schon letztes Jahr hat, hat sie mir auf den Weg gebracht. Und dieses Jahr hat das weiterentwickelt. Ich muss sagen, ich habe Lazio und Milan zum Beispiel gemacht. Das war im Januar, das war ein 4-0. Die haben Milan hergespielt, vom anderen Stern. Klar, das muss man dazu sagen, das war in dieser so schlechten Milan-Phase. Aber trotzdem, kurz darauf haben sie Juve daheim geschlagen. Da haben sie Juve auch 60 Minuten sowas von dominiert. Also Lazio hat wirklich in der Saison einen so, ja, fassenweise attraktiven, aktiven Fußball gespielt. Das schönste Beispiel, das mir so hängen geblieben ist, ist, ich würde mal sagen, 95 Prozent der Mannschaften versuchen, wenn es irgendwo eng ist, wenn der Gegner tief steht, wenn kein Raum ist, da wegzukommen, rauszukommen, sich Raum irgendwo anders zu suchen. Und bei Lazio hatte ich in den besten Fassen das Gefühl, die wollten bewusst in den engen Raum reinspielen, weil sie A, Spieler haben, die sich da drin wohlfühlen, die Luis Albertos, die Pedro, die Zaccanis, die Felipe Andersons, also viel Qualität, aber halt auch B, Sarri, ihnen sozusagen das Handwerk sozusagen mitgibt, die Instrumente, um das aufzulösen. Also es war extrem dominanter Fußball, mit einer hohen Viererkette eben auch dieses Raum verknappen und dann auf engen Räumen Lösungen finden. Das witzige ist ja, sie haben Barca 26, 27 mal zu Null, Lazio hat 21 mal zu Null gespielt, aber nicht tiefstehend, sondern mutig nach vorne verteidigend. Romagnoli und Casale, die zwei Innenverteidiger, die unbedingt Sarri haben wollte, haben genau das umsetzen können. Also Lazio, wirklich muss ich sagen, großartig. Und weil Mario sagt, ja, das mit der Doppelbelastung, das war mit Europa League und Conference League immer eine absolute Katastrophe, und da ist Lazio für mich wirklich... Ne, das ist krass. Also Lazio seit Jahren... Du brauchst die in der Europa League und Conference League gar nicht erst antreten lassen. Das bringt nichts. Die haben keinen Bock drauf. Bei der Champions League bin ich mir sicher, schaut es anders aus. Darf man auch nicht vergessen, in Sage, bevor er zu Inter kam, ist mit Lazio auch ins Achtelfinale gekommen und ich glaube schon, dass Lazio jetzt auch mit den Sicherheiten wirtschaftlicher Natur, jetzt wissend mit der Champions League, klar, bei Milinkovic-Saric schaut es so aus, als könnte er gehen, aber ich glaube, der Rest wird bleiben, die werden ein bisschen was dazuholen. Also ich freue mich wirklich sehr auf die in der Champions League, weil wenn die diesen dominanten Fußball, den sie teilweise in der Serie A gezeigt haben, auch europäisch mal versuchen zu spielen, bin ich sehr gespannt. Ein letzter Punkt dazu, die haben wirklich in der Serie A gegen die Großen performt. Sie haben Napoli geschlagen, sie haben Inter geschlagen, sie haben Milan geschlagen, sie haben Juve geschlagen und sie haben beide Derbys gegen die Roma gewonnen. Also sie haben es sich wirklich auch verdient, in den direkten Duellen sozusagen da am Ende dazustehen und deswegen echt Hut ab vor Maurizio Sarri.
Werden in der Champions League, glaube ich, in Top 4 sein, übrigens. Das kann ja spannend sein.
Definitiv.
Na Gott sei Dank haben wir bald nicht mehr diese Gruppen, sondern bald ja endlich dann quasi die Super League nur im Gewand der Champions League. 24, 25 geht's los, liebe Freunde, da können wir uns alle drauf freuen. Nochmal 200 Spiele mehr. Geil, geil, geil.
Sollen wir noch ganz kurz vielleicht, weil es Mario angerissen hat, ich glaube, Maldini und Milan müssen wir schon ganz kurz noch zwei, drei Sätze dazu. Also ich fand, der amerikanische Eigentümer bei Milan hat sich, hat es zuletzt sehr gut gemacht, hat sich zurückgehalten und so, aber ich muss sagen, jetzt die Entscheidung, ja, da gäbe es vieles, was mitwabert. Man kann Maldini vorwerfen, dass der Letztjährige transfermacht. Das war nicht gut, was da passiert ist. Also Origi hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Dest war überhaupt kein Faktor. Decatelare hat nicht funktioniert, aber Decatelare würde ich gerne in Klammern setzen, weil es gibt bei Milan die Beispiele von Tonali und Liao, die im ersten Jahr auch überhaupt nicht funktioniert haben. Und im zweiten Jahr dann kamen und was sie heute sind, glaube ich, sieht jeder, deswegen Decatelare würde ich erst final bewerten. Nächstes Jahr, falls er noch da ist, wenn er da auch nicht funktioniert, klar, dann müssen wir nicht drüber reden, dann ist es ein Flop, aber da würde ich noch warten. Ja, das kann man ihm vorwerfen, aber nochmal finde ich, ich finde, man muss halt immer die Frage stellen, wo kommt ein Verein her und wo war Milan vor drei Jahren? Wer hat Milan auf dem europäischen Zettel vor drei Jahren gehabt? Und wo steht Milan jetzt? Also auch diese Saison, klar, in der Liga war es schwierig und logisch hattest du als Meister eine andere Anspruchshaltung, aber man muss vielleicht auch ehrlicherweise sagen, der Meistertitel im Jahr zuvor, der kam vielleicht auch einen Tick zu früh. Also klar sagst du nicht, okay, nehme ich nicht, sondern du nimmst den sehr gerne, aber in der Wicklung der Mannschaft vielleicht wäre das erst in zwei, drei Jahren, sage ich mal, der folgerichtige Weg gewesen. Und dieses Jahr, ich finde, das ist mir auch manchmal zu klein, die waren im Champions League Halbfinale. Also warum soll man an Milan oder auch an Inter den Anspruch haben, dass die sowohl in der Liga als auch europäisch sozusagen bis zum Ende dabei sind? Es gibt genau eine Mannschaft, der das gelungen ist und das ist Manchester City. Die waren bis am Ende überall dabei, haben auch beides geholt. Kein Barca, kein Real, kein PSG, kein Bayern, kein, wie alle anderen großen Engländer heißen, hat es geschafft, sowohl in der Liga als auch europäisch sozusagen den ganz, ganz langen Run zu machen. Und dementsprechend bin ich auch bei Milan. Ich finde der Weg immer noch der richtige. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die entwicklungsfähig ist, die immer noch Potenzial hat. Und deswegen dieser Schritt, sich von Maldini zu trennen, nicht clever, finde ich aus Milans Sicht. Weil Maldini halt auch so viel mehr für diesen Verein ist, als nur ein Sportdirektor. Also ich hoffe nicht, dass ihnen das um die Ohren fliegt.
Ich werde jetzt nicht fragen, ob es da Verbale und Handgreiflichkeiten, ob es da gab im Auflösungsgespräch. Das ist was, das kann man ja in Serie A, Moria bestimmt nachhören. Ich denke, da wird es ausschließlich darum gegangen sein. Wie hat er dieses?
Es war anscheinend ein sehr kurzes Gespräch. Der wurde reingeholt und wurde ihm gesagt, das war's. Und dann durfte er wieder gehen. Also auch vom Stil her fragwürdig, mit einem Paolo Maldini so umzugehen, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, muss man sich leisten können. Und das ist die Frage, ob man das gerade kann. Aber das werden wir ja in der Zukunft sehen, nachdem wir jetzt schon alle Europapokal-Teilnehmer kurz besprochen haben, bis auf Atalanta Bergamo. Lass uns das noch kurz machen und dann machen wir das gleiche, auch noch in La Liga. Was ist denn zu Atalanta zu sagen?
Bemerkenswert konstant. Immer wieder schafft es Gasperini, mit seiner Art Fußball spielen zu lassen und mit der Art, wie der Verein geführt wird, dass es ein klares spielerisches Konzept gibt, das über den Spielern steht, da trotzdem wieder oben anzuklopfen. Es war keine leichte Saison. Und es ist eigentlich jedes Jahr, dass ich im Sommer zu Christian sage, Atalanta dieses Jahr, wirklich. Dieses Jahr reicht es nicht.
Mario wartet nur darauf.
Dieses Jahr reicht es nicht. Da sitzt es schon dran, wenn es auf der Acht ist. Aha, da ist meine Saison.
Ja, und auch, Mario, bis wenige Spieltage vor Schluss auch noch im Champions League rennen. Jetzt am Ende, klar, sind sechs Punkte. Aber bis vier, fünf Spieltage vor Schluss waren sie auch noch drin. Und ich finde, sie haben so diese Weiterentwicklung geschafft, so diese Erneuerung. Sie haben sich mit Heul und mit Scalvini verjüngt, haben auch ihren Stil ein bisschen angepasst, sind ein bisschen direkter geworden. Coop Miners hat eine großartige Saison gespielt, der Niederländer da im Zentrum hat komplett das An sich gerissen. Ja, sie sind junger, sie sind schneller geworden. Und Gasperini, so wie es aussieht, macht auch weiter. Also es geht dann auch anscheinend ins achte Jahr. Und ich finde, klar kann man sagen, Atalanta waren ja die Einzigen da vorne drin, die nicht die Doppelbelastung hatten. Also die konnten sich nur auf die Liga konzentrieren. Aber ich finde trotzdem, wenn du dich als Atalanta mit den zwei Mailandern, mit den Römern, mit Juve, mit Napoli misst, einfach auch von den Möglichkeiten her, dann ist das schon großartig, wenn am Ende dieser Platz fünf wieder dasteht und du sogar immer oder lange an der Champions League zumindest dran gerochen hast. Also ich finde gerade Heul und uns Calvinis sind dann zwei, da kommen wir später nochmal drauf, die Spieler, die vielleicht noch, wo noch mehr kommt, also Atalanta, Lukman hat eine großartige Saison gehabt oder zumindest lang, bevor er von Verletzungsproblemen verschont blieb.
Gut, dann haben wir die Europapokal-Teilnehmer aus der Serie A. Dann lassen wir uns noch auf La Liga blicken, denn da haben wir noch nicht über Real Sociedad gesprochen, über Villarreal noch nicht und noch nicht über Betis. Und dahinter ist dann schon der Cut. Also es war dann eher die Frage, welcher Wettbewerb würde es da werden? Fabian, vielleicht magst du mal anfangen. Was ist denn zu den dreien noch zu sagen, die wir ja zum Teil im Fall von Real Sociedad hier an der Champions League sehen werden?
Das ist auch, würde ich sagen, die Mannschaft, die es am meisten verdient hat, dort noch rein zu kommen. Alle anderen waren auch zu unkonstant. Und San Sebastian war noch die konstanteste Mannschaft ohne die großen drei, die wir vorher schon besprochen haben. Dementsprechend auch verdient mit Sicherheit auch nicht das Team, das den viertstärksten Kader hat oder das viertstärkste größte Budget, aber ein sehr gutes Umfeld. Wir haben darüber im Rasenfunk auch schon gesprochen mit einem sehr guten Trainer, der aus dem eigenen Verein stammt, der den Verein lebt und liebt und das auch seine Spieler weitergibt. Die haben nach schwierigen Jahren sehr viel auf die Jugend gesetzt. Es ist nicht mehr so, dass alle Spieler gleich automatisch zur Athletik Bilbao gehen, wenn sie richtig gut sind, oder dann noch zu größeren Vereinen, sondern die können auch gute baskische Spiele inzwischen selber halten, haben ein schickes neues Stadion. Es macht bei denen tatsächlich auch Spaß, zuzusehen. Ich denke, die haben es wirklich auch verdient, diesen vierten Platz. Alles, was darunter kommt, ich glaube von Platz 5 bis Platz 10, das waren dann drei, vier Punkte Unterschied. Das war alles sehr, sehr unregelmäßig dieses Jahr in Spanien. Keine Konstanz. Da hätte es wahrscheinlich nach zwei Spieltagen noch mal ganz anders ausgesehen, wenn diese Saison noch länger gelaufen wäre. Also ich denke, von den erwähnten, die jetzt noch europäisch spielen, ist San Sebastian definitiv die konstanteste Mannschaft gewesen und hat es dementsprechend auch verdient, nächstes Jahr Champions League zu spielen.
Vor allem muss man bei L'Areal auch erwähnen, das hieß sich jetzt auch mal, Fabian hat es schon gesagt, verdient usw., aber das war jetzt auch nach so vielen Jahren, wo sie schon immer in der Hinrunde auch mal in der Tabellenspitze waren und dann immer irgendwie in der Rückrunde eingebrochen, aber da hat sich jetzt hier und da doch ein bisschen was im Verein geändert oder in der Mannschaft, was trotzdem immer noch die zweitjüngste Mannschaft der Liga nur war, es hat noch einen jüngeren Schnitt, also dass einfach Real Sociedad da auch ein bisschen ekliger geworden ist, denn in Europa, wenn man so Statistiken anschaut, keine Mannschaft leistet sich mehr Fouls pro Partie, da ist Real Sociedad mit 16 Fouls pro Partie die, ja, so gesehen, ekligste Mannschaft in Europa, ohne dass sie jetzt viele Karten haben, aber sie wissen einfach, wo sie dann doch mal irgendwie dem Gegner irgendwie den Ballbesitz unterbinden und sind da einfach auch ein bisschen cleverer geworden, trotz so einer jungen Mannschaft mit so vielen Eigengewächsen Du hattest auch einen kleinen minimalen Umbruch im Kader, das mit Alexander Isak, der beste Spieler der Vor-Saison im Sommer gegangen ist. Der wurde jetzt gut von Sirloot ersetzt. Du hattest dir dann auch noch einen anderen Mittelstürmer geholt. Aber da auch Umar Satic von Almeria ist auch die ganze Saison verletzt ausgefallen. Also das ist absolut beachtlich, was da eben der Trainer Immanuel Alguacil da hingestellt hat. Und dass da einfach auch viel konstanter Arbeit geleistet wird. Also wäre Alguacil nicht, wäre vielleicht mittlerweile Xabi Alonso da, der die zweite Mannschaft trainiert hatte. Aber dort wird irgendwie auf Alguacil gesetzt, auf die Nachwuchs gesetzt und nach jetzt über vier Jahren führt das jetzt noch mehr zum Erfolg. Also das ist eine sehr gute Geschichte, die da Real Sociedad schreibt. Und ich würde gleich noch einen Ticken weitergehen. Du hattest, glaube ich, noch wie Real und Betis genannt, aber es gibt sogar mit Ossas Hunan noch einen Europapokal-Teilnehmer. Als siebten sind die zumindest in der Conference League dabei. Dank Real Madrids Pokal-Sieg haben die sich qualifiziert. Und auch da ist das Stichwort die Kontinuität. Denn Alguacil ist der drittdienstälteste Trainer der Liga. Und Arasate von Ossas Hunan ist der zweitdienstälteste Trainer. Und auch dort überschaubarer Kader oder überschaubares Budget. Viel Eigengewechsel, viel Nachwuchs. Und das wird einfach auch dort sehr viel gelebt. Und der ist jetzt auch schon fünf Jahre da. Und die belohnen sich jetzt auch nach einer sehr guten Saison. Sie waren die letzten Jahre immer irgendwie auf Platz neun, zehn, elf, was schon auch sehr konstant und gut ist. Jetzt waren sie im Pokalfinale. Da sind sie an einem noch cleveren, abgezockteren Real Madrid gescheitert, aber haben sich da auch noch für die Saison belohnt und sind siebter geworden. Also das wird dort auch gefeiert. Ohne Enden Pamplona da, Osas Hunan, Real Sociedad. Das ist definitiv so eine Feel-Good-Story aus La Liga. Und ja, wir Real Betis, das hätten auch noch andere werden können. Ich weiß nicht, jetzt darf auch Alex mal.
Ja, ein Wort noch zu Real Sociedad. Es ist wirklich ein organisches Wachstum. Der Verein ist bis in die Champions League hochgewachsen, hat sich das über Jahre verdient. Durch tolle, tolle Arbeit, Kontinuität, klares Spielsystem, klare Philosophie. Die Spiele haben sich weiterentwickelt. Le Normand hat es jetzt sogar in die spanische Nationalmannschaft geschafft, weil die französische Nationalmannschaft kein Interesse an ihm hatte. Didier Deschamps hat zugegeben, er schaut keine Spiele von Real Sociedad an. Er spielt nicht öffentlich auf einer PK zugegeben. Er spielt nicht bei Barca, er spielt nicht bei Real Madrid, er spielt nicht bei Atletico. Ja, da bekomme ich es halt einfach nicht so mit. Sein Zitat. Die Spanier waren happy, haben ihn jetzt für die Nations League nominiert. Also ein Innenverteidiger mit der Zukunft noch vor sich, ein sehr, sehr guter Mann, der sich da gut entwickelt hat. Zu Beldia, zu Bimendi, zwei weitere Spieler, die aus der eigenen Jugend kommen und die sich stetig einfach über Jahre jetzt unter Immanuel Alguacil weiterentwickelt haben und so das Rückgrat bilden. Und das Rückgrat ist einfach auch sehr, sehr, ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, stabil, nämlich bei der Arbeit gegen den Ball. Sie sind sehr, sehr stark, sehr, sehr schwer zu knacken. Das war letztes Jahr schon, da hatten sie, glaube ich, sogar mit die beste Abwehr mit Real Madrid. Jetzt ist natürlich Barca noch mal on top, was das anbelangt. Aber sie sind da einfach sehr, sehr schwer zu knacken. Stabiles System und ja, die Mannschaft, die sich absolut verdient hat, endlich wieder Champions League zu spielen. Zum dritten Mal, glaube ich, erst in der Vereinsgeschichte. Na Nils, wie war das alle zehn Jahre? Schaffen sie es mal. 2003, 2013, jetzt 2023 Champions League.
Ja, dann weiß man ja, wann es wiederkommt. Ich muss die Low-Hanging-Fruits pflücken, wo sie nur zu haben sind.
Aber ich finde, das ist echt wirklich so eine Feel-Good-Story. Ich gucke wenig spanischen Fußballer. Zum Beispiel das Pokalfinale habe ich gesehen. Fand es richtig nice mit Osasuna. Ich habe damit mitgefiebert und es ist toll, dass es in allen Ligen so Vereine gibt, bei denen sich Kontinuität, eine Philosophie und gute Arbeit immer noch lohnen kann. Und dass für 4, 5, Platz 6, 7 reicht, was für dich selber als Fan ja mega geil ist. Denen ist es scheißegal, ob der Meister oder der 2. Platzierende mit der Premier League mithalten kann und noch mehr Geld kriegt, sondern er freut sich dann darauf, wenn er irgendwo bei Ligia Warschau einmal irgendwie auswärts fahren darf und das alles miterlebt. Oder auch ein Platz 9 kann da so viel wert sein, wenn du dich dann damit identifizierst. Ich glaube, bei den, auch in Spanien, von den genannten Vereinen, da leben dann die Leute den Verein und das macht das ja auch aus. Ich muss das auch öfter mal für mich selber wieder sagen, dass so balsam auf die Romantikers Seele ist. Es ist noch nicht alles verloren.
Es ist nicht alles schlecht.
Magst du den mal quer vergleichen? Ich glaube, man kann so ein bisschen zum SC Freiburg vergleichen von der Entwicklung des Vereins. Nicht die Vereine an sich, also dort ist es wesentlich größer als Freiburg, aber von der Entwicklung des Vereins. Du hast Kontinuität in der Mannschaft, auf der Trainerposition, klare Philosophie. Und der Verein nimmt Step-for-Step, klettert die Stufe hoch. Bei Freiburg hat es ja leider zum zweiten Mal in Folge nicht geklappt mit der Champions League. Also das hat es eben geschafft, aber natürlich auch, weil zum Beispiel der FC Sevilla in der La Liga da so geschwächelt hat, aber eben jene Konstanz, das ist schon eine schöne Feel-good-Story und freut mich auch persönlich, dass Lareal da endlich in der Champions League spielt.
Von Feel-good-Story zum Abstiegskampf, lass uns darüber noch kurz sprechen. Wir bleiben mal noch in Spanien. Am Ende hat es jetzt erwischt, Valadolid, Espanyol und Elche. Elche hat im Grunde nicht mehr verloren, seitdem es klar war, also ein bisschen später, als es klar war, aber irgendwie sensationelles Finish, nur leider halt völlig umsonst. Ansonsten war es aber sehr spanisch. Wer nicht abgestiegen ist, sind Almeria, Valencia, Retafel und Cadiz. Über alle haben wir mal zumindest kurz gesprochen, vor allem Valencia, haben wir schon relativ früh hier thematisiert im Rasenfunk, dass es um die sehr schlecht steht oder stand in dieser Saison. Jetzt hat man es geschafft. Fabian, was würdest du sagen, ist wichtig zu diesem Abstiegskampf zu wissen, jenseits des Ergebnisses eben, wen es getroffen hat und wen nicht?
Bei Valadolid wird es jetzt interessant werden, den Ronaldo hat, also der Präsident Ronaldo, der Brasilianer Ronaldo, hat er eigentlich vor, glaube ich, den Verein zu verkaufen. Hat er anscheinend schon so einen Deal mit einem amerikanischen Investor für 80 Millionen und wollte dann eigentlich...
Ist doch günstig, ja?
So Medienberichte. Ist ein kleiner Verein. Darf man nicht überbewerten. Und in Spanien kriegt man auch nicht sehr viel Fernsehgeld. Na ja, egal. Auf jeden Fall ist dieser Investor jetzt abgesprungen, weil er die 2. Liga nicht interessiert. Jetzt muss er vielleicht doch noch weiterarbeiten, was ich wiederum positiv fänden würde. Denn ich finde, er hat einen ganz tollen Job gemacht. Wie gesagt, es ist ein kleiner Verein. Den hat er eigentlich mit sehr viel Herzblut geführt und auch von der 2. Liga in die 1. Liga geführt und ich glaube, er hat einen Fehler gemacht. Er hat den Trainer Pacheta, der war schon der Aufstiegstrainer, er hat ihn entlassen vor zwei Monaten oder so, drei Monaten. Und der war eigentlich so ein bisschen sinnbildlich für dieses Valladolid gestanden. Er ist auch einer der spanischen Fußballphilosophen, wie ich finde. Hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal angesprochen, Max. Und da hat er sich glaube ich in ein richtig schönes Eigentor geschossen. Denn Valladolid ist dann danach eben auch nicht wirklich besser geworden, sondern hat jetzt eben den Schritt in die 2. Liga oder muss jetzt den Schritt in die 2. Liga gehen. Ganz dramatisch auch in einem Heimspiel gegen Getafe, dass man nur hätte gewinnen müssen und man wäre drin geblieben. Und so hat Getafe wieder geschafft. Getafe ist auch so ein Verein, wie ich finde, persönlich zumindest. Der muss nicht in der ersten Liga sein. Das ist so, naja, nicht Heidenheim, aber so in die Richtung hier zu sehen.
Soll ich Augsburg sagen?
Komm, ich sage Augsburg.
Ihr wollt es ja eh alle hören.
Wenn Augsburg wusste, wie oft das hier vorkommt in dieser europäischen Ligatur.
Getafe ist ein kleiner Madridter Vorrat. Die haben ein kleines Stadion. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob da immer noch die Leichtathletik-Bahn dran rum ist. Da passen 15.000 Leute rein.
Ganz so schlimm ist es nicht.
Es ist auf jeden Fall für mich kein Erstligaclub eigentlich. Aber gut, sie haben es geschafft. Man muss es ihnen lassen, mit Borrolas, der übrigens bei Valencia entlassen worden ist diese Saison. Interessanter Trainerkopf. Bei Espanyol Barcelona tut es mir auch ein bisschen leid. Ich fand es immer sehr schön, diese Barcelona-Duerbis und so weiter. Da finde ich auch Reichenvereine in die 1. Liga gehört. Aber die haben es leider verkackt dieses Jahr. Wir haben auch einen chinesischen Investor. Da läuft auch nicht alles rund hinter den Kulissen, was man so hört. Und wie du schon gesagt hast, bei Elche stand es schon relativ früh fest. Die haben dann am Schluss noch mal einen aufgespielt. Wahrscheinlich, weil die Spieler ja auch sehen müssen, wo sie nächstes Jahr gerne spielen möchten. Da haben sie sich dann nur noch ein bisschen angestrengt. Aber auf jeden Fall der verdienteste Absteiger natürlich, keine Frage.
Generell kann man zumindest sagen, dass auf jeden Fall Spannung dort gegeben war. Ich glaube, am vorletzten Spieltag konnten noch 7 Teams absteigen. Und am letzten Spieltag waren es dann noch 6 Teams, die theoretisch mathematisch hätten absteigen können. Weil Dolit hat es in der eigenen Hand. Valencia hat sich dann doch noch gerettet, hat mathematisiert, weil irgendwie dort kam der Faktor Nachwuchs dazu, dass eben der neue Trainer Ruben Barraja, der sehr viel auf noch mal irgendwie eigene Wechsel gesetzt hat, da sind auf einmal Jungs rumgelaufen mit Trikot Nummer 44, 41, die dann auch noch entscheidende Tore in der 90. Minute gemacht haben. Also dort ist da noch mal was Neues entstanden, was dann Valencia irgendwie gerettet hat. Also diese zwei Punkte über der Abstiegszone, das hätte sie auch noch am letzten Spieltag erwischen können. Aber das war so ein bisschen der Faktor. Espanol mit den Mitteln hätte schon eher noch bleiben können, aber die haben einfach die erste Hinrunde verschlafen. Auch dann eben erst gegen Ende auf einmal ist sie aufgefallen. Aber wir können doch ein bisschen offensiver spielen mit Josselou und Bradford, also zwei eigentlich sehr guten Stürmern. Also da war schon einiges los. Ritaffe wie immer, minimaler Ballbesitz, etliche Fouls. Das ist wenig Fußball, auch katastrophale Passgurten. Also ja, auch denen hätte man irgendwie den Abstieg zutrauen können. Aber es sind da jetzt Steigner trotzdem, Teams, die jetzt nicht der ganz große qualitative Verlust sein würden. Auch in den FC Cardis, die haben sich gerettet. Stehen jetzt auch nicht für den großen Zauberfußball oder mit Megafieber.
War es, die haben immerhin 30 Tore gemacht in 38 Spielen. Weiß gar nicht, was du hast.
Ja, das ist schon. Ich habe mehr, habe ich weniger.
Nichts gegen meine analysischen Vereine hier.
Aha, da ist es wert.
Im Tegitaka-Klubkast sind wir auch pro Kadis, Nils und ich.
Also das ist eher als Reise hin.
Geile, geile Stadion, geile Fan-Kultur. Kadis ist so ein bisschen ein Auli in Spanien. Muss man, sollte man schon dabei haben. Almeria übrigens noch ganz interessant. Max, wenn ich noch mal kurz vom Alex reingerätschen darf, ist ja der Scheich-Club von dem Saudi-Sportminister-Präsident irgendwas. Blabla. Der Saudi-Chef, der sich auch mal Messi nach Hause einlädt und Zidane und so mit denen quatscht. Weiß nicht, was da so ein Nachmittag kostet, aber egal. Und da ist der Trainer gegangen freiwillig, obwohl er den Klassen halt geschafft hat. Die sind jetzt auf Trainersuche und ich denke, der wird aber auch noch mal ein paar Milöntchen jetzt reinlegen in seiner zweiten Erstligasaison. Also auf die Entwicklung von Almedia sollten wir einen Ruhiglein werfen. Da könnte was passieren.
Nochmal ein Nachtrag zur Retafel. Gegen Violit im Endspiel haben sie glaube ich 59 Pässe an den eigenen Mann gebracht. Wir reden da fast schon von Kreisliga. Wahnsinn. Die haben nur auf dieses 0 zu 0 gespielt. Und Bordalas, der wahrscheinlich Jahrhundert-Trainer, retafelt, wenn man ehrlich ist. Der hat sie ja mal nach Europa gebracht und ist ja bekannt für seine 0-0 oder 1-0s. Hat halt eben sein 0-0 wieder erkämpft. Damit haben sie die Klasse gehalten. Und Violit musste das Spiel machen. Man weiß ja, wie schwer das einem Abstiegskandidaten fällt, wenn sich die andere Mannschaft hinten reinstellt, dass du da was kreierst. Vor allem in Spanien ist da ja immer sehr, sehr wenig los. Mit Blick auf die Tore und Torchancen und Torschüsse etc. Von daher, ja. Retafel hat sich borderlassmäßig zum Klassenerhalt 0-0.
Ja, also es waren 64 Pässe, die angekommen sind.
64, sorry.
Aber auch nicht so viel.
Macht's massiv besser.
49 Prozent.
Ich lag komplett daneben.
41 Prozent Passquote, 20 Prozent Beibesitz.
41 Prozent Passquote.
41, hab ich auch noch nie gehört.
Noch nie. Noch nie. Ein Expected-Goals-Wert aus einem Spiel von 0,03. Also das war wirklich von Anfang an. Und man konnte das ja verfolgen. Man muss sagen, also der Abstiegskampf, ihr habt es ja schon gesagt, es war super spannend. Man konnte das sehr gut über die sozialen Netzwerke auch verfolgen, selbst wenn man es nicht gesehen hat. Ich hab auch immer, ich bin immer so geswitcht zwischen den Spielen, die ich mir da angeguckt habe, weil es keine Konferenz gab. Ja, die hab ich aber nicht gefunden. Da war der Anwender dann das Problem. Sicherlich war das ganz toll präsentiert und ich hab's einfach nur übersehen. Auf jeden Fall hab ich dann immer zwischen den Spielen geswitcht, aber es gab ja so lange Nachspielzeiten, dass man ja dann am Schluss wusste, okay, jetzt guck ich mir hier noch die 13-Minuten-Nachspielzeit an, dann werd ich wahrscheinlich wissen, was passiert. Und bei Hitafa hab ich aber kein einziges Mal vorbeigeguckt, weil da hab ich schon bei Twitter gelesen, dass es richtig, richtig räudig ist. Und hab mir dann gedacht, nee, also dann, das guck ich ja oft genug für meine anderen Sendungen hier im Rasenbunk.
Warte, ich möchte nicht nur... Also die 41% Passquote stimmen, oder wie?
Jaja.
Wahnsinn. Also Hellas hatte am letzten Spieltag in San Siro gegen Milan 58%. Und da dachte ich mir für mich, wow, 58%, das geht nicht weniger. Wow, 41% ist da dann doch noch mal ein deutlicher Schritt nach oben.
58% kriegst du in der 2. Deutschen Bundesliga häufiger, oder? Wenn der 1. FC Nürnberg spielt, Nils oder so, da gibt es nicht immer so viel.
Saisonschnitt des FC Retafels sind 71%, also das ist auch der schwächste Wert in La Liga und wahrscheinlich mit in Europa.
Nee, nee, in Europa auf gar keinen Fall. In Europa sind die Bundesliga-Vereine, die mit den schlechtesten Passquoten...
Siehst du, jetzt kommt gleich wieder Augsburg.
Augsburg, Platz 1, 28% Passquote. Bochum, Platz 2, 69,9. Dann kommt Retafel, Platz 3. Dann kommt Hertha, dann kommt Mainz, dann kommt Schalke. Und die Bundesliga hat nämlich insgesamt 6 Vereine in den Top 10 mit der schlechtesten Passquote.
Union auf 9.
Union auf 9. Freiburg kommt dann irgendwann auf 18. Wir haben das allerdings im Rasenfunk-Royale-Taktik-Segument auch noch mal aufgelöst. Man muss sich jetzt nicht nur an der Passquote aufhängen, weil es hängt auch an dieser Verbindung zwischen langen Pässen und Vertikalspielen nach Ballet-Eroberung und so weiter. Und wenn man sich anguckt, wie Gladbach seine Superpassquote erreicht hat, dann denkt man sich, das kann es jetzt auch nicht sein. Aber Ritave da nur auf Rang 3. Das möchte ich noch zur Ehrenrettung von Ritave sagen. Es gab noch zwei natürlich Bundesligisten, die schlechter waren. Das muss hier sein. Und natürlich fällt hier wieder das Wort Augsburg. Ich kann ja auch nichts dafür. Die Stadt Augsburg. Aber damit sind wir ja schon im Abstiegskampf bei der Serie A. Denn da gibt es ja die schöne Regel, oder ja doch, ich glaube, ich finde sie schön, die Regel, dass bei Punktgleichheit es ein Entscheidungsspiel gibt zwischen den Vereinen, die im Punktgleich sind, um dann eben den Abstieg. Da habe ich jetzt leider nicht reingeguckt, obwohl ihr ja das Vergnügen hattet, das zu kommentieren. Ich habe mir aber die Statistiken angeguckt und dachte mir so, hm, also die einen haben in der ersten Hälfte 3 Tore gemacht, die anderen 1. Es stand 3 zu 1 dann für Hellas. Und in der zweiten Hälfte habe ich statistisch gesehen, nur ein Team gesehen, aber die haben halt überhaupt keinen Tor mehr gemacht und deswegen müssen die jetzt absteigen.
Genau, das Spezia geht runter. Die Regelung haben sie diese Saison nochmal installiert. Davor gab es immer direkten Vergleich. Und die Regelung hätte auch diese Saison beim Meisterschaftskampf gegriffen. Also das geht dann für 1 und 2 und 17, 18. Das Spezia geht runter. Es war ein Abend, wir haben gestern gesagt, in dem wirklich alles gegen die lief. Am Anfang sehr verunsichert, nochmal zurückgekommen, Hellas war griffig, die Tore gemacht. Das war das Spiel, das wir überhaupt nicht erwartet haben. Also wir hätten eigentlich Haus und Hof auf 0 zu 0 gesetzt. Ein richtig räudiges Fußballspiel.
Schön vier Tore in der ersten Hälfte, das hat mich auch gewundert.
Was für Tore teilweise.
Teilweise richtig geile Tore, es ging hin und her. Und dann auch der Knackpunkt war in der zweiten Halbzeit ein sehr gut aufgelegter Torhüter von Hellas. Montipo hat alles rausgeholt, inklusive eines Elfmeters. Das war 20 Minuten vor dem Ende, als der Kapitän von Hellas, Faraoni, den Ball Suarez-like, auf der Linie mit der Hand über die Latte lenkt und ihm erst eine Sekunde später bewusst wird. 20 Minuten vor Schluss machte das bei 3-1-Führung. Rot und Elfmeter und erst als er den Platz verlassen hat, hat er gecheckt, was er gerade gemacht hat. Und Spezia verschießt den Elfmeter.
Montipo heilt den. Im Nachhinein hat er alles richtig gemacht.
Geht ganz genau wie Suarez damals.
Ja, das Besondere war, bei Suarez war es wirklich Nachspielzeit und klar machst du das, finde ich. Und da, wie Mario gesagt, da waren halt noch 20 Minuten auf der Uhr und wenn der Elfmeter drin ist, das steht 3-2, dann bist du auch noch in Unterzahl. Aber klar, im Nachhinein hat er es richtig gemacht, weil Spezia hat halt weiter Druck gemacht, Montipo hat gehalten, gehalten, aber das eine Tor ist halt nicht gefallen. Wahrscheinlich hätten ihnen danach auch nur noch ein paar Minuten gereicht, um zumindest nochmal Druck zu machen. Und so war es dann am Ende. Ich fand es auch verdient für Hellas. Die erste Hälfte war gut. Und auch da schließt sich jetzt der Kreis zum Thema Statistik. Hellas ist nämlich auch so eine Mannschaft, die über eine sehr schlechte Passquote kommt. Aber es hat eben genau, wie du vorhin gesagt hast, damit zu tun. Die gehen auf Ballgewinne, auf hohe Ballgewinne oder auch und versuchen dann einfach vertikal schnell in die Spitze. Das bringt dann absolut mit sich, dass die Zahlen dahingehend bei der Passquote nicht gut aussehen. Aber wenn das dazu führt, dass du im alles entscheidenden Spiel und mehr als Abstiegs-Endspiel in 90 Minuten geht halt nicht, in der ersten Hälfte dann daraus drei Tore erzielst und die hätten auch noch zwei weitere machen können, weil sie sich wirklich große Chancen herausgespielt haben, dann würde ich mal sagen, ist das das beste Beispiel dafür, dass Statistik in Zahlen allein nicht immer alles sind, sondern in dem Fall hat Hellas ja den richtigen Ansatz gefunden und im Do or Die halt dann auch das Ganze dann gut über die Bühne gebracht.
Aber eine Statistik will ich trotzdem noch dropen, weil wir gestern so oft darüber geredet haben. Stürmer von Hellas, Milan Djuric. Gestern ist er eine zweite Vorlage gemacht und nur ein Tor in der Saison, aber absoluter Stammspieler und mit der wichtigsten Mann, er ist Serie A weit der Spieler mit den prozentual meisten gewonnenen Zweikämpfen als Stürmer. Der gewinnt 70% der Duelle und das war gestern immer ein langer Ball, er gewinnt das Kopfball-Duell. Klar, er verlängert dann auch manchmal den Ball ins Nichts. Das geht dann glaube ich trotzdem als gewonnener Zweikampf oder so. Aber das war faszinierend, weil sonst hat ja ein Stürmer mal so um die 50, 60, weiß ich nicht genau.
Also wirklich 70% bester Zweikämpfer der Liga. Allein das steht da in der Luft, eine absolute Macht. Und das Schöne war, das Spiel geht los und nach vier Sekunden kommt der erste lange Ball auf mich. Ja, weil Fußball kann halt manchmal auch einfach sein. Und wie Mario gesagt hat, es geht ja auch gar nicht immer drum, dass er jedes Kopfball-Duell gewinnt, sondern im Idealfall rückt dann Hellas, geht auf zweite Bälle, rückt nach. Und das haben sie in der ersten Hälfte einfach sehr gut gemacht. Machen die drei Puden und damit haben sie dann einen Grundstock gelegt. Und ja, am Ende, wenn du jetzt drin bleibst, dann hast du dahingehend alles richtig gemacht, auch wenn die Hellas-Saison ganz sicherlich keine gute war. Aber jetzt gehst du auch noch mit dem positiven Erlebnis da raus. Ja, war irgendwie schon ein spezieller Abend. Oder ich finde, wir haben ja auch darüber geredet, auch 90 Minuten für einen Elfmeterschießen. Es hätte auch noch einen Elfmeterschießen nachgegeben. Also es hätte keine Verlängerung gegeben. Bei Unentschieden wäre es direkt ins Elfmeterschießen gegangen. Und ich finde, weil wir jetzt viele europäische Finals hatten, klar, wenn du ein Finale verlierst, das ist wahnsinnig bitter. Und da knabberst du lange dran. Aber irgendwann wird dir ja auch bewusst, dass du auch einen guten Weg gegangen bist und kannst was Positives irgendwann mitnehmen. Aber bei so einem Abstiegs-Endspiel, 90 Minuten, der Verlierer, ist halt einfach alles im Allerwertesten. Also ich finde diese Drucksituation, die da da war, schon eine sehr, sehr besondere. Auch nicht dieses Hin und Drück-Spiel, sondern 90 Minuten heute Abend entscheidet sich hier. Neutraler Ort. Neutraler Ort, genau. Also eine spezielle Konstellation.
Ja, und da hast du auch gemerkt, Spezia hatte mehr zu verlieren. Die standen eigentlich konstant immer überm Strich. Hellas hat sich nochmal rankämpft und hatte mehr zu gewinnen. Und wirkte ein bisschen befreiter.
Das ist bitter. Definitiv. Also bei Spezia muss man auch dazu sagen, da haben einige Stammspieler gesperrt oder auch verletzt gefehlt. Das war auch bitter. Das ist dann logisch auch, wenn du in das alles entscheidest. Also die Bank von Hellas war sechs Mann länger. Spezia hat überhaupt sechs Spieler weniger auf der Bank gehabt, weil so viel nicht sozusagen spielfähig war.
War Spezia das Team mit dem Fan, der so weit gereist ist, oder war das ein anderes? Könnt ihr euch noch erinnern, der diese Auswärtsfahrt mitgemacht hat und dann von den gegnerischen Fans gegrüßt wurde, haben wir irgendwann hier im Rasenfunk auch mal gesprochen.
War das nicht Südtirol?
Ich glaube auch, das war der FC Südtirol.
Ja klar, natürlich. Meine Güte. Die haben es auch nicht geschafft.
Nee, der hat es auch nicht geschafft. Nee, gestern eben können wir ja auch gleich. Es gab nämlich Parallel, auch ganz interessant. In Italien lief Parallel zum Abstiegs-Endspiel, lief das Aufstiegs-Rückspiel-Endspiel sozusagen.
Gratulation an diese Terminierung.
Ja, definitiv. Und geschafft hat es Caliari. Mit an der Seitenlide Sir Claudio Ranieri.
Klar, da wäre ich drauf gekommen.
Durch Achtung, ein Tor in der 94. Ohne das Tor wäre Bari hochgegangen. Also gestern in Italien war echt gut was los nochmal.
Bitte sag, dass es das 1 zu 0 war.
Es war das 1 zu 0. Nee, hätte es eben nicht. Weil in Serie B-Playoffs ist es so, wenn es sozusagen bei Tor-Gleichstand setzt sich da in der Saison besser platzierte durch. Bari war auf 3 am Ende der Saison.
Ich dachte erst nach der Verlängerung.
Nee, nee, nee. Also Caliari hat den Sieg gebraucht. Und der Sieg kam in 90 plus 4.
Ja gut, so kann man auch in Belgien Meister werden. War es nicht auch 90 plus 4? Herzlichen Glückwunsch an Marc van Bommel an dieser Stelle. Und irgendein Schalker spielt da, also Ex-Schalker. Aber kann mich gerade nicht mehr dran erinnern, wer das war. Auf jeden Fall auch dazu. Herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Bereichen. Und Thilo Kehrer ist Europe Conference League Final-Gewinner. Der erste deutsche Spieler, wenn das stimmt, habe ich irgendwo bei Twitter gelesen, bei Ex-Profis oder so. Na ja, also auf jeden Fall, herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu. Wollen wir noch was zu Cremoneso und Sampdoria sagen? Die sind ja runtergegangen. Vor allem im Fall von Sampdoria kam das wie aus dem Nichts mit ihren 19 Punkten.
Ja, ich meine, Cremoneso hat tatsächlich Spaß gemacht noch. Eine lange Zeit. Hätten es fast noch mal, obwohl sie mega weit hinten waren, also ganz weit letzter mit erfrischendem Offensivfußball, sich dann noch mal ran gespielt. Im Endeffekt reichen dann auch, er fehlen vier Punkte. Das ist, finde ich, dann versöhnlich. Klar, freut sich nicht über einen Abstieg, aber die hatte man eigentlich als abgeschlagenen 20. auf dem Zettel. Und dafür haben sie es echt noch ganz gut hinbekommen. Bei Samp ist es natürlich mega bitter. Also so ein Traditionsverein, der so vor die Hunde geht, auch finanziell gerade drunter und drüber. Der, sagen wir mal, extrovertierte Präsident, der hat ja auch irgendwie den Verein jetzt über Jahre hinweg zugrunde gerichtet, auch wirtschaftlich gesehen. Der Jans Dankovic hat da in der Seitlinie nichts mehr ausrichten können. Der CFC kommt wieder hoch, aber Samp geht halt runter. Und das ist tatsächlich auch, man hat die Trikots vor Augen. Man hat Quaerella, der eventuell in der Serie Biers noch mal weiter macht.
Macht vielleicht weiter.
Im Übrigen eher der Spieler, der jetzt 18 Saisons in Folge in der Serie A getroffen hat. Fabio Quaerella. Aber Samp ist halt so ein Verein, der gehört für mich eigentlich einfach dazu. Aber das war einfach unterirdisch.
Darf ich die Brücke schlagen nach Spanien? Traditionsverein, der vor die Hunde geht. Mein Beileid an Fabian Pakulat, der FC Malaga, ist in die dritte Liga abgestiegen.
Wenn wir ihn hier schon zu Gast haben.
Ja, habe ich mich schon seit Wochen, Monaten damit beschäftigen dürfen und können. Und es passiert einfach mal. Wir haben vor der Aufnahme noch kurz darüber gesprochen, was dann mit Deportivo La Coruña auch passiert ist. Die spielen jetzt seit fünf Jahren in der dritten Liga, schaffen es nicht mehr hoch. Es ist sehr, sehr schwer, wenn man mal abrutscht, wieder hoch zu kommen. Und jetzt hat es uns erwischt nach jahrelanger Misswirtschaft, muss man ja leider so sagen. Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, nächstes Jahr, was mich da erwartet. Im Spanien-Ritterliga kenne ich es auch noch nicht. Wird interessant. Ich weiß, dass man zumindest Bier trinken darf im Stadion in der dritten Liga. Das darf man in den ersten zwei nicht. Das ist zumindest ein kleines Highlight.
Wenn ihr sehen könntet, wie er dabei gegrinscht hat, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Sehr leicht ironisch. Aber ja, ich werde euch davon berichten, was da alles passiert. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob Katar noch Interesse jetzt weiter hat, den Verein zu kaufen. Wir werden sehen, was die 3. Liga in Spanien zu bringt. Also ich werde es vor allen Dingen sehen.
Ist denn da der finanzielle Drop-off auch so krass wie in Deutschland? Also man hat ihn logischerweise zwischen 1. und 2. Liga auch. Aber hier in Deutschland ist ja 2. und 3. Liga, das sind ja richtige Welten. Darunter brauchen wir ja nur mal Hachenfragen. Glückwunsch zum Aufstieg. Aber wann wusstet ihr, ob ihr überhaupt meldet für die 3. Liga? Ach so, einen Tag vorher, cool. Wie ist denn das in Spanien?
Ja, also ich denke mal, von einem guten Budget in der 2. Liga in Spanien spricht man so von 20 Millionen. Ein gutes Budget in der 3. Liga ist 5 Millionen. Also da ist der Bruch schon ziemlich krass. Im Endeffekt wird kein Spieler bleiben, außer ein paar Nachwuchstalente, die schon gespielt haben. Der Großteil muss gehen, du musst eigentlich ein komplett neues Team stellen. Du musst einfach alles umreißen. Der FC Malaga hat jetzt auch ein Massenentlassungsverfahren eingeleitet. 60 Mitarbeiter werden jetzt entlassen.
Das ist immer krass, bei so einer Geschichte.
Klar, die ganzen Büro-Mitarbeiter, sage ich jetzt mal, oder was außenrum noch so dabei ist, dafür ist einfach kein Budget mehr. Der Verein muss jetzt krass schrumpfen. Dann werden wir mal schauen, wie es weitergeht. Wir haben jetzt endlich eine Sportstadt, die jetzt im Oktober eröffnet wird. Das hatte der FC Malaga gar nicht. Der musste immer in einem Nebenplatz hinter dem Stadion trainieren, auf sehr unprofessionelle Art und Weise. Wir haben viele gute Talente hier in Andalusien, auch in der Provinz Malaga. Wenn wir schaffen, die zu halten und vielleicht relativ bald wieder aufzusteigen, dann kann der Verein sich jetzt auch vielleicht gesunden, auf sportliche und finanzielle Art und Weise. Aber es wird ein langer Weg, ein harter Weg, ein steiniger Weg.
Ein großer Unterschied zwischen der deutschen dritten Liga und der spanischen dritten Liga ist auch, vor ein paar Jahren war die dritte Spanische Liga bestanden noch aus vier Gruppen mit jeweils 20 Mannschaften. Das wurde 2021 reformiert. Jetzt sind es immer noch zwei Gruppen mit jeweils 20 Teams. Und auch deswegen ist es so schwer, da hochzukommen. Du hast dann noch die jeweils ersten steigen natürlich direkt auf und dann die Plätze zwei bis sechs, glaube ich, haben Playoffs. So ist jetzt auch Deportivo mal wieder dran gescheitert. Also das ist superschwierig. Und auch da merkt man, wenn du einfach mal mit 40 Teams konkurriert, konkurrierst, ist natürlich nochmal der Wettbewerb mal anderer als vielleicht die deutsche dritte Liga, wo es nur diese eine Gruppe gibt.
Ja, krass. Gibt übrigens Studien dazu, die haben es bloß noch nicht ins Bewusstsein des Fußballs geschafft, dass das das eigentliche Problem von vielen Sportligen ist. Die Angst vor dem Abstieg ist aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht völlig berechtigt, weil der Cut so groß ist. Und dann fangen nämlich Teams an, sich zu verschulden. Nur kurzfristig zu denken und so weiter, weil eben dieser Aufschlag in der unteren Liga so hart ist. Und in Ligen, das gibt es dann vor allem in anderen Sportarten, wo das eben viel weniger Unterschied macht, ob du dritte, zweite oder erste Liga spielst. Da hast du einen viel ausgeglicheneren Wettbewerb, weil nämlich alle gar nicht so sehr ins Risiko gehen müssen. Weil selbst ein Abstieg bedeutet dann eben nicht, dass du 50 Prozent der Mitarbeitenden entlassen musst. Aber gut, das ist nur ein anderes Thema. Wir haben auch noch andere Themen, die können wir ja... Ja, unter anderem. Also gut, das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Wir wollen jetzt aber auch über skurrile Geschichten sprechen, wenn wir schon beim HSV sind. Nein, wir haben noch so ein paar lockere Fragen, die wir einfach jetzt mal hier so, können wir auch wegen mir gerne mischen, wer da vorlegt. Ich sag jetzt einfach, Nils darf mal loslegen. Was war denn so eine skurrile Geschichte dieser Saison, die du in guter Erinnerung behalten wirst?
Eine skurrile Geschichte habe ich vorbereitet. Da geht es auch schon um einen der besten Spieler der Saison, vielleicht sogar der beste Spieler der Saison. Wo seine Geschichte, die skurrile Geschichte, da kam es mehr in der Hinrunde dazu. Es geht um Antoine Grießmann. Der war ja vor, wie war das, 2019 ist er zum FC Barcelona gewechselt. 135 Millionen Transfer. Fühlte sich dort nicht ganz so wohl, kam nach zwei Jahren zurück. Und ja, der hat jetzt in dieser Saison quasi jeden Spieltag bestritten, aber nicht immer vom Beginn an. Das waren, glaube ich, die ersten sechs oder sieben Spieltage, wo er immer erst in der 60. Minute herum eingewechselt wurde. Und man wusste genau, ah, nächsten Spieltag wird er wieder erst so, rund um die vielleicht auch mal 70. Minute eingewechselt. Warum war das so? Weil zwischen Barca und Atletico da eine Vertragsklausel war. Wenn Grießmann in diesen zwei Leihjahren, wo er von Barca zurück zu Atletico ist, mehr als 50 Prozent der Spielzeit gemacht hätte, hätte Atletico, ich glaube 40 Millionen, zahlen müssen, verpflichtend an den FC Barcelona. Und nachdem er in seinem ersten Leihjahr schon ziemlich oft eingesetzt wurde, war dann in der zweiten Saison jetzt die Ansage, den müssen wir ein bisschen runterschrauben. Und einfach auch Atletico hatte gehofft, da in so einen Poker zu kommen mit Barca, weil die konnten ihnen sich auch nicht leisten das Gehalt, wollten ihn auch gar nicht mehr zurückhaben sportlich. Dass das 7 Millionen, wie gesagt, die ersten 7-8 Spieltage stohisch immer erst, kriegt nur seine 25-Minuten-Einsatzzeit. Und Barca ist dann tatsächlich eingeknickt. Ich glaube, diese verpflichtende Ablösesumme von 40 Millionen wurde dann runtergeschraubt auf 20 Millionen. Und so ist dann zu diesem skurrilen Transfer überhaupt nur dosiert eingesetzt zu werden. Muss man sagen, Barca hat da, glaube ich, für Grießmann 115 Millionen, 135 minus 20 gezahlt, für zwei Jahre. Und er hatte auch schon seine paar Türchen. Aber das ist für mich so rundum den vermutlich besten Spieler der Saison, konstantesten Spieler der Saison, der auch sehr viel Leichtigkeit versprüht hat. Das war so eine sehr skurrile Geschichte. Zumindest aus der Hinrunde.
Ja, weil man muss sich das mal vorstellen. Er ist wahrscheinlich der beste Spieler der Liga gewesen in der Saison. Passt wirklich perfekt zu Giorgio Simeone, zu Atletico. Man weiß, wie sehr Giorgio auf ihn setzt und wie sehr er ihn auch schätzt, auch als Menschen, auch als Person. Und dann sind ihm da die vertraglichen Hände gebunden, weil der Verein ihm sagt, du kannst ihn nicht vor der 60. einsetzen. Weil sonst droht diese Klausel, dass wir die zahlen müssen. Diese 40 Millionen können wir uns nicht leisten wegen Corona. Also auch Atletico hat finanzielle Probleme, nicht nur der FC Barcelona. Corona hat da in Spanien viel kaputt gemacht. Und dann haben sie eben gepokert. Und haben sich aber sportlich quasi selbst die Hände gebunden. Unter anderem glaube ich im San Siro, da hat er getroffen gegen Milan in der Champions League nach Einwechslung. Oder ich glaube, da hat er schon gespielt, weil das war nur Champions League von Anfang an. Bin mir nicht sicher. Aber ganz, ganz komische Story. Definitiv eine der kuriosesten Stories in der Liga. Und nachdem er eben dann fest verpflichtet wurde, nicht mehr wegzudenken, zum besten Spieler der Liga ist geworden.
Verrückt. Alex, was ist deine Skurrilität dieser Saison?
Ja, auch vertraglich, ehrlich gesagt. Auch eine vertragliche Sondergeschichte. Nämlich die Gavi-Story bei Barca, der seinen Jugendspieler-Vertrag hat von Barca Athletic, der 2. Mannschaft, die in der 3. Liga spielt. Mit dem Vertrag ist er angetreten. Dann hat die Vertragsverlängerung schon verkündet, dass er Profi-Spieler wird, dass er einen Profi-Vertrag bekommt, dass er die Rückennummer 6 bekommt, denn die Jugendspieler haben Rückennummern ab, ich glaube 27 aufwärts. Dann hat La Liga gesagt, ja, nee, der Vertrag ist nicht gültig. Also Barca hat die Vertragsverlängerung mit Profi-Vertrag verkündet offiziell und alles. Und La Liga hat dann gesagt, nee, könnte nicht machen, hier finanzielle Restriktion mit Blick auf die Gehaltsobergrenze, die ja in Spanien gilt, die keine andere Liga übrigens hat. Ganz, ganz besondere Story da auch. Dann war plötzlich kein Profi-Spieler mehr. Dann hat Barca im Winter geklagt. Das ist auch übrigens typisch La Liga, typisch Spanien, dass man bei irgendwelchen Gerichten klagt. Und dieses Gericht hat Barca dann stattgegeben. Ja, ihr könnt ihn einsetzen, das ist alles rechtens. Der hat einen Profi-Vertrag. Also hat Barca wieder verkündet, ja, er ist Profi-Spieler der ersten Mannschaft mit der Rücken Nummer 6, darf da auflaufen. Dann hat La Liga dagegen geklagt. Zwei Monate später hat La Liga wieder Recht bekommen. Dann wurde ihm die Rücken Nummer 6 wieder genommen. Und der alte Vertrag war wieder gültig, also der Jugendspieler-Vertrag. Und jetzt muss man mal abwarten. Offenbar hat Barca jetzt auch wieder Recht bekommen, also wieder dagegen geklagt, damit er jetzt doch wieder Profi-Spieler ist mit Profi-Vertrag und der Rücken Nummer 6. Also ganz, ganz kurioses Story-Star. Sportlich natürlich, man konnte ihn einsetzen, egal mit welcher Nummer, egal mit welchem Vertrag. Aber dass Barca da klagt gegen La Liga und dann Recht bekommt und dann aber wieder La Liga dagegen klagt, anstatt dass man das irgendwie untereinander bespricht, geht man da vor Gericht. Sowohl der Verband als auch der Verein. Ja, ganz, ganz zwielichtige Nummer, aber irgendwie typisch La Liga. Nils, das ist einfach so in Spanien. Kann man nicht, kann man nicht, in den Bundesliga-Fan kann man das nicht erklären, was das für komische Dinge da sind.
Nein, wie auch die Verbandspräsidenten von quasi spanischem DFB und der spanischen Liga-Verband Tebas und Rubiales sich öffentlich immer streiten. Und egal, was der eine macht, der andere schießt direkt einen Tweet hinterher, ist einfach peinlich. Und ja, auch diese ganzen Streits, und Lewandowski-Sperre aufgeschoben, er durfte dann doch einmal spielen. Ja, ganz viel.
Also wenn ein Spieler gesperrt wird und dem Verein passt das nicht, dann wird er erst einmal von einem Gericht geklagt. Lewandowski war dann einsatzfähig, weil das Gericht quasi die Sperre, die drei Spiele Sperre ausgesetzt hat. Und La Liga hat dann dagegen geklagt. Ja, nee, das ist jetzt doch gültig. Aber solange das Gericht quasi den Fall bearbeitet, wird ja die Sperre ausgesetzt. Deswegen war Lewandowski einsatzfähig im Derby gegen Espanol, obwohl er offiziell gesperrt ist.
Ich kenne ja Menschen aus der Bundesliga, die Angst haben, dass das das Vorbild sein könnte, für die deutsche Liga, wenn die Solidargemeinschaft, die viel beschworene, aufgebrochen wird. Das ist ja ganz offensichtlich so. Es wollten ja auch Barca und Real und Atletico in die Super League. War Atletico dabei? Genau, waren anfänglich dabei. Aber die sind zurück und die anderen beiden ja. Also Real ist ja jetzt das letzte verbiebene Mitglied der Super League, nachdem jetzt auch Juve gesagt hat, ach irgendwie, doch nicht. Aber ich kenne einige, die sehr viele La Liga-Beispiele dieser Art gegen einen vorbringen, wenn man sagt, warum habt ihr XY und so und so in der DFL entschieden, dass sie sagen, wir wollen nicht, dass es zu Zuständen kommt wie eben dort. Und über die Gehalts-Obergrenze werden wir auch so in ein, zwei Jahren vielleicht mal ausführlicher sprechen müssen, wenn man dann auch sagen kann, was hat das eigentlich so bewirkt und sich verändert, weil das ist ja wirklich bemerkenswert, dass es dieses Instrument einfach in La Liga gibt und sonst nirgendwo. Was ja auch ein Wettbewerbnachteil sein könnte, nicht müsste. Ja, das muss man dann mit ein bisschen Abstand, glaube ich, bewerten. Da ist es jetzt noch ein bisschen früh. Christian, skurrile Geschichten gab es sicherlich auch in der Serie A.
Eins noch ganz kurz, weil ich weiß nicht, ob es diese Saison war oder war es letzte Saison, als der spanische Verbandspräsident mit Piquet das Supercopa-Engagement quasi die beiden abgestimmt haben, dass sie die spanische Supercopa ja jetzt in Saudi-Arabien austragen lassen, weil man dafür ja viel Geld bekommt, mehrere Millionen. Und das wurden dann WhatsApps veröffentlicht in dem Piquet und Rubiales, der Präsident des spanischen Verbandes, dann eben die Deals ausgemacht haben. Also wir sind dabei, wir kriegen nur mal vier Millionen. Real ist dabei, die kriegen auch schon mal vier Millionen. Die kriegen das und wir machen das alles so. Und wir kommen dann ins Finale und du kriegst dann auch noch mal zwei Millionen und dann machen wir das so irgendwie. Es wurde alles öffentlich gemacht. Danach gab es eine tolle Pressekonferenz des spanischen Verbandespräsidenten, in dem er gesagt hat, pass mal auf, ich rauche nicht, ich trinke kein Bier. Ich bin als Kind von meiner Schwester überfahren worden und ich habe mir überhaupt nichts zu Schulden kommen lassen. Und hatte wirklich so gesagt, kein Bier.
Hatte er den Redenschreiber von Johnny Infantino?
Ich glaube, die haben sich vorher ausgetauscht. Das war sein Statement dazu.
Ja, und was er noch gesagt hat, ist von wegen, ja, das wurde ja abgehört und die Leaks, meine WhatsApp-Nachrichten wurden geleakt. Und wer weiß, wie sie mich noch überwachen und verhören und wie ich abgehört werde, am Ende des Tages vielleicht findet man ein Päckchen Kokain in meinem Auto, weil ich weiß ja nicht, wer das... So sind die Methoden hier. Ich werde kriminalisiert, quasi durch Kräfte von außen. Und wer weiß, am Ende steckt mir vielleicht irgendeine dritte Person auch noch Kokain in den Kofferraum.
Rücktritt gab es natürlich keine.
Gab es natürlich keine, natürlich nicht.
Jetzt aber vorbei mit Skurrilität.
Aber Kokain im Kofferraum, da können wir uns gleich an den Ibiza-Video erstellen.
Das war seine Verteidigungsrede. Man weiß ja nicht, was die anderen gegen einen machen.
Ich wollte es mischen, du wärst noch drangekommen, Fabian. Aber dann haben wir jetzt La Liga, Skurrilität, Apehandel. Christian, Serie A, was ist dir in der Erinnerung geblieben?
Ich nehme Napoli und Zamdoria rein, erste und letzte. Mario hat es hier vorhin schon angedeutet. Ein Fakt dazu, Zamdoria hat in der ganzen Saison weniger Tore geschossen als Viktor Ossimen allein. Aber die Skurrilität an sich ist für mich, es gibt zwei Spieler, die sind sowohl Meister gewonnen, als auch abgestiegen. Nämlich Bartosz Beresinski, polnischer Nationalspieler, auch WM-Teilnehmer. Der hat mit Zamdoria die Saison angefangen, ein absoluter Stammspieler, und ist dann im Winter zu Napoli gewechselt. Er hat jetzt sozusagen die Meisterschaft gefeiert und kommt jetzt zu dem Verein zurück, der abgeschlagen abgestiegen ist. Und den umgekehrten Weg hat Alessandro Zanolli gemacht, junger Außenverteidiger von Napoli. Für den hat es sich sicher gelohnt. Deswegen hat Napoli auch im Winter den Deal eingetütet. Sie wollten einen erfahrenen haben, eventuell als Backup. Und Zanolli hat bei Zamdoria Spielpraxis bekommen. Wunderbar. Und der kommt jetzt zurück, zwar auch als Absteiger, auch als Meister, weil er hat in der Hinrunde auch für Napoli gespielt. Und da, glaube ich, ist einer, dem traut Napoli viel zu. Der wird jetzt erst mal Backup vom Capitolen di Lorenzo. Also, ja, glaube ich, hat man nicht jedes Jahr, dass ein Spieler gleichzeitig Meister wird und auch absteigt.
Und die haben ja beide am letzten Spieltag gegeneinander gezockt.
Auch noch gegeneinander gespielt.
Als es den Pokal gab. Und Zanolli, ein Junge aus Napoli, der hat sozusagen im Samtrikot ein bisschen Meisterfeier miterleben dürfen. Ich muss bei der Kuriositätengeschichte auch bei Napoli bleiben. Wir hätten das ja einmal, glaube ich, schon angesprochen in einer vorherigen Folge, dass Spalletti das Trikot mit seinem Gesicht drauf bekommen hat. Und dass es dann von allen Spielern auch gab. Da muss ich ja wirklich die Trikots dieses Saison von Napoli. Es gab eins mit einem Rudolf the Red Nose Reindeer. Es gab eins zum Valentinstag mit einem Kussmund drauf. Es gab eins mit Maradona. Es gab ein Auswärtstrikot, ein Champions League-Trikot, ein Heimtrikot. Dieses Meister-Spalletti-Trikot. Und zur Krönung dann auch nochmal ein T-Shirt mit der Drei drauf für den dritten Meistertitel. Und auf der Drei eine Unterschrift vom Präsidenten. Also der nimmt sich selber hier nicht so wichtig, auch über die Lorente.
Als ob der Präsident ein Filmmogul wäre, keine Ahnung.
Also das tatsächlich, diese fast zehn käuflich zu erwerbenden Stofffetzen für immer 120 plus. Chapeau, das muss man auch erstmal schaffen.
Gab es dieses Jahr kein Halloween-Trikot? Das ist ja enttäuschend. Ich hab's doch auch immer. Die Spinne gab's mal.
Ich fand's schon schade, als er gesagt hat, und zur Krönung auch noch, dachte ich, ein Trikot zur Krönung von Kim Paz.
Der Lorentes hat sich ja auch ganz zurückhaltend, als das Codetto übergeben wurde, als Allererstes die Medaille umhängen lassen. Also vor den Spielern, vor dem Trainer. Und er war der Erste und danach kamen, glaube ich, vier oder fünf... Na, direkt der Verwandte. Also Klaas, sein Sohn, ist ja, glaube ich, auch mit involviert, aber seine Frau hat dann auch eine Medaille bekommen und erst dann kamen sozusagen die Spieler, die Betreuer.
Wie in den USA.
Ja, und er hat das auseinandergehen mit Spalletti, war auch ein bisschen komisch. Spalletti hat das, glaube ich, ja vorher schon bekannt gegeben und der Lorentes hat dann auch ein bisschen Macht gespielt und dann kam Spalletti raus und das war so... Mein innerer Ironiedetektor ist kurz angesprochen, weil Spalletti so hingegangen ist und so fast so eine Art leichten Handkuss bei der Lorentes angedeutet hat.
Also der Lorentes könnte auf jeden Fall... Also wäre auf jeden Fall einer fürs Oberbürgermeisteramt in Frankfurt. Das kann man, glaube ich, so festhalten. Sehr schön. Dann wollen wir noch sprechen über Spieler und Trainer der Saison und zwar vielleicht nicht über die offensichtlichen Namen. Also weil wenn Antoine Griezmann, der beste Spieler in dieser Saison in La Liga war, dann ist es zwar eine interessante Info, aber den kennen wir alle. Mich interessiert vor allem, wen werden wir vielleicht kennenlernen? Und dann werdet ihr sagen und zwar... Und auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer werden sagen, ja Moment mal, das habe ich ja 2023 im Rasenfunk schon gehört. Ich kannte ihn schon, bevor er cool wurde. Wen gibt es da, Christian, in der Serie A?
Wollen wir mal mit Trainer anfangen?
Ja, lass mit Trainer anfangen.
Da werfe ich mal Raffaele Palladino in den Raum. Der Monza-Trainer, Monza ganz kurz zur Einung. Kein normaler Aufsteiger gewesen, hat ja sehr viel investiert. Da steht ja Berlusconi dahinter, Gagliani, ist der ganze, der das managt. Haben viel Geld in die Hand genommen und waren wirklich jetzt auch am Schluss, waren bis zum letzten Spieltag auch noch im Rennen um die europäischen Plätze, also haben das wirklich auch gut gemacht. Sind aber katastrophal gestartet und Palladino hat, glaube ich, nach dem 5. oder 6. Spieltag, wo sie alle Spiele verloren haben, übernommen und hat wirklich großartige Arbeit geleistet. Also Palladino, Ex-Spieler, auch bei Juve gespielt, unter Gasperini gespielt, auch so ein bisschen Gasperini-Schüler, was die Trainerarbeit betrifft, da haben wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen. Das wunderbarste Kompliment, das Palladino bekommen hat, hat er von Maurizio Sarri bekommen vor wenigen Wochen, als Monzer gegen Lazio gespielt hat. Da hat Sarri gemeint, Palladinos Mannschaften verteidigen wie Atalanta und greifen wie Guardiola-Mannschaften an. Und man muss jetzt dazu sagen, Maurizio Sarri ist nicht einer der Woche für Woche irgendjemanden großen vor die Füße wirft. Das war schon ein sehr großes Lob. Palladino hat auch gemeint, wo, wo, wo, vielleicht war es ein bisschen zu hoch angesetzt. Nein, aber es trifft schon den Punkt. Also Palladino, diese Dreierkette so Atalantamäßig, wo die Innenverteidiger auch vorne mit reingehen, sehr offensiver Ansatz. Aber eben im Unterschied vielleicht zu Atalanta auch ein bisschen mehr über Ballbesitz fassen. Deswegen auch dieser Vergleich mit Guardiola. Also Palladino, wirklich ein, hat jetzt auch verlängert, finde ich, einen richtigen Schritt. Geht nächstes Jahr mit Monza in die zweite Saison. Ich bin mir sicher, Monza wird auf dem Transfermarkt auch nochmal nachlegen. Also die wollen sicher mittelfristig auch so ein bisschen Fiorentina, die, sage ich mal, die Kategorie angreifen. Und Palladino ist definitiv einer, glaube ich, den wir in den nächsten zwei, drei, vier Jahren auf dem Schirm haben sollten. War sehr ansehnlich, was Monza da gespielt hat.
Max Alegri. Wenn es nicht die ganz Großen sein sollen, dann würde ich mit Thiago Motta gehen. Sehr gute Arbeit bei Bologna gemacht. Konstanz hat auch ein bisschen gefehlt, aber da hat auch nicht umsonst schon der ein oder andere Klub mal angeklopft und gefragt, ob er denn nicht wollen würde, aber der hat ja auch auf dem Platz schon gezeigt, dass er Fußball versteht und denken kann und so. Bologna hat Spaß gemacht über weite Strecken, also auch mit einem guten Offensivansatz, viele variablen Spieler, gutes Gefüge. Und da denke ich, ja, Motta würde ich noch so nennen, weil Italiano bei Florenz war jetzt auch irgendwie, den haben wir jetzt im Finale gesehen, wäre ja kein, aber auch der gehört in die Riege der eher noch jüngeren Trainer, die wir wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Jahren noch häufiger besprechen werden.
Wen haben wir denn da in La Liga, Alex?
Ja, ich finde es schade, dass unsere England-Korrespondenten hier nicht im Call sind, denn ich würde gerne Andoni Iraola nennen von Raio. Der verlässt Raio jetzt aber und man munkelt, oder es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass er in England landen wird. Deswegen den Bogen spannen zu den Engländern. Also das ist ein Trainer, den man in ganz Europa nicht noch auf dem Schirm haben sollte, sondern jetzt im Sommer sicherlich auf dem Schirm bekommt, nämlich wenn er bei irgendeinem ambitionierten englischen Verein unterschreibt, machen die Engländer ja eh gerne, sich die besten Trainer der Welt in ihre Liga holen. Gerne natürlich auch aus Spanien, jetzt nicht nur mit Blick auf Guardiola, sondern man hat ja Unai Emery geholt, man hat Rulén Lopetegui geholt und den ein oder anderen mehr auch in der Vergangenheit. Und ich denke, Antoni Iraola, der tolle, tolle Arbeit bei Rio gemacht hat, im ganz, ganz kleinen Verein, fast Europa erreicht im ersten Jahr. Ich glaube, sie waren im Halbfinale der Copa letztes Jahr, Nils, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, oder? Weiß ich gar nicht.
Mit Mirandez war das, mit Mirandez im Zweiten.
Mit Mirandez, stimmt. Mirandez, ein Zweitligisten, wirklich so ein Heidenheim-Verein aus Spanien, hat er ins Pokalfinale gehievt vor zwei Jahren. Dann ging er zu Rio, dem spanischen St. Pauli, wenn man so will, dem Stadtteilclub aus Madrid. Einmal wurde er, glaube ich, achter, jetzt wurde er elfter. Zweimal tolle Leistung, immer wieder die Großen geärgert. Reinweise wurden Real Madrid und der FC Barcelona geschlagen. Toller Fußball, also Vorwärtsgewand, aktiver Fußball, Pressing, laufstark, ballbesitzorientiert. Ganz tolle Arbeit. Und ja, er macht jetzt den nächsten Schritt, höchstwahrscheinlich nach England. Also das ist ein Trainer, den man auf jeden Fall in ganz Europa auf dem Schirm haben sollte und auf dem Schirm haben wird.
Der ist auch erst 40 Jahre alt, also das will ich sagen, der spanische Nagelsmann, aber auf jeden Fall hat sensationelle Arbeit bei Ayo geleistet. Sollte da auf jeden Fall auf dem Schirm bleiben.
Das unterschreibe ich so. Absolut. Das ist der Mann, glaube ich, den man erwähnen muss, außer die Trainer von Osasuna und Real Sociedad, San Sebastian, die wir schon angesprochen haben. Aber Iraola ist der Mann, auf jeden Fall, auf den man achten sollte die kommenden Jahre.
Na, wenn das so ist.
Ich habe noch einen zweiten Trainer, oder willst du den? Nee, ich lasse ja Nils. Vielleicht nennst du ihn. Einen zweiten Trainernamen, den man kurz besprechen sollte.
Also ich hatte jetzt auf jeden Fall auch Iraola auf dem Schirm. Jetzt gucke ich kurz mal auf die Tabelle, wie du rein könntest.
Honorable mention an Mendilibar, den Sevilla-Coach, der die Europa League gewonnen hat. Nach wie vielen Jahren?
Über 20.
Ich glaube, er ist viermal mit vier verschiedenen Vereinen aufgestiegen. Vierte in die dritte Liga, dritte in die zweite, zweite in die erste. Aber in einem richtig großen Club in Spanien durfte er nie coachen, hat immer die Absteiger gecoacht. Eibar hat da, glaube ich, sieben Jahre lang auch einen Mini-Mini-Mini-Verein in der Liga gehalten, was ja schon grandioser Arbeit ist. Also auch da kann man gerne Parallelen ziehen zu, keine Ahnung. Heidenheim von mir aus, wenn der Frank Schmidt die einfach fünf Jahre in der...
Weil wir heute so oft schon Heidenheim gesagt haben. Nein, Augsburg haben wir oft gesagt. Aber Heidenheim ist heute auch schon ein Firma vorgekommen. Das ist ja absolut faszinierend. Aber ich meine, ich fange ja immer an mit diesen schiefen Vergleichen. Deswegen, ich bin ja schon...
Max, damit du dir auch ein Bild machen kannst, weil du ja immer, damit du das besser einordnen kannst, wie klein diese Vereine sind und was das für kleine Namen sind. Deswegen mache ich das ganz gerne, ja, um da den Zuhörer auch mitzunehmen.
Finde ich ja gut.
Ist ja auch tolle Arbeit gemacht bei dem Mini-Verein, aber eben nie irgendwie auf der Liste gewesen, dass es zu einem größeren Verein geht. Und dann ist er bei VioLig, glaube ich, sogar nach zwei Monaten entlassen worden. Und dann plötzlich aus dem Nichts kommt er als Feuerwehrmann zu Sevilla, wirklich nur um die in der Liga irgendwie zu halten. Also so Valencia-Style quasi, die wären schon vorgewesen, wenn sie irgendwie drei Punkte über dem Strich stehen. Und plötzlich machen sie diesen Europa-Pokal-Run und gewinnen dieses Ding schon. Und er feiert seinen ersten Titel in seiner Trainer-Karriere, ich glaube, im Alter von 62 oder irgendwie sowas. Also ganz, ganz besondere Story da. Natürlich jetzt nicht mit Blick auf die Zukunft, dass er jetzt irgendwie da irgendeinen anderen Verein übernehmen wird und seine Karriere da noch antreiben wird. Aber er hat jetzt eine Vertragsverlängerung bekommen, völlig zu Recht natürlich bei Sevilla. Und ja, dass er einfach seinen ersten Titel, seinen richtigen ersten Titel feiern konnte. Ganz, ganz schöne Story.
Und Luis Enrique sucht noch einen neuen Verein, der vielleicht im Sommer sich finden lässt.
Da können wir die Brücke schlagen zu den Italien-Korrespondenten.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das Suchen ist nicht das Problem. Ich glaube, der ruft ganz nette Summen aus. Ne, ne, auch nicht das Finden. Also De Laurentiis hat sich, hat auch, also Napoli-Präsident hat auch offen gesprochen, dass da mal Kontakt war, aber gesagt für Luis Enrique sind anscheinend Gehaltsfähren. Da will oder ja, will Napoli auch gar nicht mitmachen. Also da deutet laut De Laurentiis auch vieles darauf hin, dass es richtig in England geht oder, also ich glaube, da geht es nicht darum, dass er nicht Angebote hat, sondern ich glaube, er sucht sich da das raus, das für ihn auch wirtschaftlich das Interessanteste ist. Weil ich würde mal sagen, spannend wäre Napoli im Moment schon auch, klar, mit der Mannschaft kannst du schon auch was machen. Ich hätte es total charmant, oder ich würde es total charmant finden mit Luis Enrique. Aber ja, De Laurentiis meinte wohl, das sind andere Kategorien, da spielen wir nicht mehr.
Aber dass er sehr eigen ist, das wisst ihr schon. Er war ja schon bei der Roma in Italien. Und da war er auch nicht ganz so von der Öffentlichkeit gegründet.
Wir haben doch auch schon mal über Enrique gesprochen. Ich weiß aber gerade nicht, ob es da um Tottenham oder Chelsea ging. Aber bei einem von beiden...
Er war bei Chelsea auf dem Zettel als einer von zwei, drei Kandidaten mit, ich glaube Tuchel und jetzt... Nicht Tuchel, Nagelsmann, sorry. Und jetzt Pochettino, das er wurde. Also ich glaube, da war einer von drei sehr, sehr gut gestellten Kandidaten. Aber was hinter den Kulissen passiert?
Ja, wollen wir vielleicht auch gar nicht wissen. Dann lass uns aber noch kurz über Spieler sprechen, die ganz groß noch rauskommen könnten. Also Spieler, die wir vielleicht dann in ein paar Jahren noch auf einem ganz anderen Level sehen. Dann fangen wir wieder mit der Serie A an. Wenn wir hier schon sind. Ihr guckt euch fragend an, wen feuert ihr raus?
Ja, ich habe zwei Namen. Der eine ist es auch kein No-Name, aber einer, der unter dem Radar fliegt, zumindest für Leute außerhalb Italiens und der nächstes Jahr noch mal mehr performen wird, in der mich immer wieder fasziniert ist. Domenico Berardi bei Sao Solo. Eigentlich haben wir gedacht, da bleibt er auf jeden Fall. Jetzt vielleicht Lazio. Das wäre dann tatsächlich ein sehr spannendes Element, der sehr gut den linken Fuß bereitet vor, schließt ab, bis 6. in der Scorer-Liste insgesamt 19 Torbeteiligungen. Und mein zweiter wäre eins drüber, wenn man die Top-4 ganz, ganz großen Namen ausklammert, Boulayer Dia von der Salanitana, der da mit 22 Torbeteiligungen unfassbar viel dazu beigetragen hat, dass die sich mega souverän im Endeffekt in der Serie A gehalten haben. Hochspannender Stürmer, der vermutlich nicht mehr allzu arg lange in Salerno bleiben wird.
Klassischer Mittelstürmer oder Flügelsstürmer?
Wenn ich befreunde, das ist falsch. Schon eher zentral.
Zentral, aber kann auch was am Füßchen. Also das ist es keiner, dem du anschießen musst.
Also Dia hätte ich auch genommen. Echt auch so von der Athletik ein bisschen, finde ich, erinnert auch ein bisschen an Ossi Men. Also auch so lange, raumgreifende Schritte. Wie Mario gesagt hat, 16 Puden, 6 Vorlagen. Also da waren nur Leo Lautaro und Ossi Men vor ihm. Also wirklich die höchste Kategorie und ist ausgeliehen aus Spanien. Da zieht die Salernitane jetzt auf jeden Fall. Die haben die Option und es heißt, dass er eine Klausel reinbekommt. Also das könnte vielleicht sogar schon diesen Sommer heiß werden. Es hieß auch schon mal, dass Milan dran war. Also für mich auch ganz spannender Spieler, der Physis und Abschlussqualitäten mitbringt. Weil Mario bei Sassuolo war, ich bleibe auch bei Sassuolo, Armand Lorientet, Außenstürmer. Berardi kam über rechts, Lorientet über links. Unfassbar guter 1 gegen 1-Spieler. Super-Dribbler. Hat die meisten erfolgreichen Dribblings noch vor gewissen Herrn Leao und Quaratzkelia. Also einer, der in dem Game wirklich drin ist. Weil zum Saisonende war verletzt. Hat auch davor, ist ihm vielleicht die ganze Nummer so ein bisschen zu Kopf gestiegen. Die Anise, dass der Swallow-Trainer den auch ein-, zweimal öffentlich angezählt. Auf Pressekonferenzen so vom Wegen, Herr Junge, schon weitermachen. Also nicht aufhören jetzt sozusagen, aber wirklich von den Fähigkeiten her. Wirklich einer, der dieses 1 gegen 1 dauernd sucht, immer ins Dribbling reingeht, guten Abschluss auch, gute Assists, also als Assist-Man auch funktionieren kann. Also das ist einer, der das Potenzial hat, da definitiv noch durchzusteigen. Und dann machen wir dieses Vodoo-Ding zu, würde ich sagen, ich bleibe auch weiterhin bei Fratesi. Also Mittelfeldspieler, der wird jetzt auch bald den nächsten Schritt machen. Es ist nur eine Frage, ob er dann in Italien bleibt, vielleicht geht er auch nach England, da sind alle Großen dran. Dynamischer Mittelfeldspieler, torgefährlich, so ein bisschen für mich Richtung Barella, ganz gutes Gespür für den Raum auch. Der wird für mich in den nächsten Jahren ganz sicher den nächsten Schritt machen.
Sehr gut, da sind ein paar interessante Namen mit dabei. Und viel Sassuolo, das ist also geblieben. Das war ja letzte Saison oder vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, auch schon so, dass man quasi jedes Sassuolo-Spiel einfach angucken konnte. Weil da haben doch dann auch, das waren doch die nominierten Nationalspiele, die dann bei der EM wichtig geworden sind, oder?
Ja, das waren die Locatellis und ebenso viele, die da rauskamen. Und da landen wir halt auch wieder bei De Zervi. De Zervi hat das Ganze halt mit initiiert als Trainer, hat die da hingebracht und die gehen, würde ich jetzt sagen, den Weg mit Dionysia auch weiter. Klar, das war die Saison auch wieder so rauf und runter. Nicht konstant, aber halt immer gute Spiele. Die kannst du immer gegen Großen anschauen. Die haben halt heuer auch wieder fünf Buden in San Siro gegen Milan gemacht. Klar. Klar, fährst halt nach San Siro und machst fünf Buden. Ganz normaler Sonntagnachmittag, oder?
Aber haben wir dann auch halt wieder vier Spiele, wo sie irgendwie gegrünt, keinen Bock haben. Da ist kein Druck drauf. Das ist ja so ein kleiner Verein. Das ist eine Mischung aus Hoffenheim, Leverkusen, Komfortzone, keiner will was, gewinnst ein Spielchen wieder, bis zwölfter, ist egal, zockst, da kriegst du gutes Geld.
Ich bin völlig bei dir. Das ist kein Druck auf den Verein, aber den Spielern scheint es ja gut zu tun, weil sehr viele Spieler da wirklich, ja, Entwicklungsschritte machen, die sie dann halt auch, die sie dann halt weiterbringen. Und da kommen sicherlich noch ein paar raus, ja.
Okay, also, die werden wir alle im Blick behalten. Fabian, wen müssen wir denn in La Liga ins Auge fassen?
Ja, da bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, wen ich jetzt daneben von meinen zwei Favoriten, aber ich nenne jetzt mal Gabriel Vega von Celta Vigo. 21-jähriger Offensivspieler, der hat, glaube ich, dieses Jahr 11 Tode gemacht und hat vor allen Dingen mit seinen zwei Treffern am letzten Spieltag Vigo in der Klasse gehalten und ist eigentlich...
Gegen Barca.
Gegen Barca und ist ein sehr, sehr interessanter Mann und wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht lange noch bei Vigo spielen, denke ich mir.
Den hatte ich auch auf der Liste.
Ich glaube, so weiterhin werden wir in diesem Sommer woanders sehen. 40 Millionen Ausstiegsklausel. Richtig, richtig spannender zentraler offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, typisch spanisch. Er kann die Bälle halten, verteilen, dribbelstark, wendig, spielt mit unfassbar viel Selbstvertrauen. So als würde er einfach schon 4, 5, 6, 7 Jahre in der Liga spielen. Dabei ist es, glaube ich, sein zweites Erst aus der Jugend. Zeltas stammt er. Und ich glaube, Zeltas ist da gar nicht so unglücklich, weil auch die natürlich Geldprobleme haben und das Stadion gerade modernisieren, wenn da jemand diese 40 Millionen Ausstiegsklausel zieht, weil das einfach unfassbar viel Geld ist für den Verein. Und auch da habe ich schon Namen gelesen, wie unter anderem Napoli, das da mal vorgefühlt wurde. Ob da was dran ist, weiß man natürlich.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da kann ich euch sagen, dass ein paar Anrufe aus Neapel schon eingegangen sind.
In Liverpool hatte ich auch gelesen, dass der bei 40 halt so ein Betrag ist, den kann sich der ein oder andere Verein einfach gut leisten. Vor allem die Engländer, für die ist ja 40 Millionen sowas wie in Deutschland.
5 bis 10 Millionen.
Von daher werden da schon die großen, international ambitionierten Vereine mit ihnen völlig zur richtigen Verbindung gebracht. Also ganz, ganz spannende Mann.
Nils, hast du noch einen? Ich war vorab gespannt, was die Kollegen sagen würden, weil ich hatte eben auch eher Gabriel Weger auf dem Schirm. Es gibt natürlich, kann man auch noch ein paar andere Namen nennen, aber so Nico Williams zum Beispiel, hatte eher so letzte Saison, also 22 so eher sein Durchbruch, ja, jetzt auch eine enorme, enorme Streuung bei seinen Abschlüssen. Barenice Schäer ist nicht der entscheidende Mann bei Real Sociedad. Kangin Li hat auch ein sehr gutes Jahr bei Mallorca hinter sich und ist da auch ein absoluter Faktor, dass die eher im Mittelfeld gelandet sind, aber ist für mich noch eher ein bisschen zu launisch, eklig auch. Und Gabriel Weger ist da eher so der saubere Kicker, so auch Straßenkicker, der einfach eine sehr hohe Genauigkeit hat und so, könnte der Aspas Nachfolger werden. Aber wird wahrscheinlich gehen. Also ich bleibe da auch eher bei einem Gabriel Weger. Und so groß ist jetzt die Nachwuchsarbeit oder Spanien ist da glaube ich eher weiter weg, aktuell von der nächsten goldenen Ära, wie damals zu den WM-Zeiten, von dem ja halt man mal an einem Weger fest.
Nicht abgesprochen, ne?
Nico Williams wäre auch mal jetzt weiter gewesen. Also der hat jetzt eine schwierige Rückrunde gehabt, aber ganz Athletik Bilbao hatte eine schwierige Rückrunde. Also von daher sei es am 21-Jährigen auch mal zugestanden, dass man auch mal kleine Formschwankungen hat. Unwahrscheinlich explosiver Spieler, schneller Spieler, Flügelstürmer, abschlussstark eigentlich auch. Und ja, der wird auch noch seine Geschichte schreiben, denke ich.
Und bei Geschichten, die geschrieben werden, sind wir auch bei der letzten Frage, die ich an jeden von euch einzeln noch habe, nämlich welche Erinnerung werdet ihr mit dieser Saison in Verbindung bringen? Was wird bleiben? Es überkreuzt sich wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen mit den Skurrilitäten und auch mit den Spielern. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja noch irgendwas, was für euch persönlich irgendwie zu dieser Saison dazu gehört. Fabian, du darfst gerne anfangen. Vielleicht geht es ja jetzt sogar wieder um Malaga.
Ja, ich war tatsächlich der Liga etwas unfremd dieses Jahr. Aber es war halt auch keine überragende Saison in Spanien. Das muss man einfach mal so sehen. Und dazu kam natürlich noch der Abstieg vom FC Malaga, von der 2. in die 3. Liga. Aber was für mich immer wieder schön ist zu sehen, und da komme ich wieder auf das Thema Fußballromantik zurück. Ich habe ein Spiel live gesehen in Bilbao. Ich glaube, Bilbao gegen Almeria 4-0 gewonnen. Da war im Halbzeitstadion immer voll. Das ist immer ein riesen Familienfest. In der Halbzeit hatten eine lokale Band gespielt. Das ganze Stadion kannte das Lied. Das ist eigentlich so eine Indie-Band. Die haben das zusammen gesungen. Da hatte die Oma die Enkelin im Arm und der Papa die Schwägerin und was weiß ich was. Und alle waren happy und alle waren irgendwie zusammen. Und das hat nochmal das bisschen deutlich gemacht, was diesen Verein einfach ausmacht, dass einfach ein ganzes Land ohne eine ganze Region dahinter steht. Und das war einfach ein schöner Moment.
Das ist wirklich ein sehr schöner Moment. Da wäre man gerne mit dabei gewesen. Alex, was hast du denn erlebt, wo man gerne mit dabei gewesen wäre?
Da muss ich die Abschiede der drei Barca-Ikonen nennen. In einer Saison sind Gérard Piquet, Sergio Busquets und Jordi Alba haben ihre Barca-Karrieren beendet. Piquet ist ja komplett zurückgetreten. Busquets und Alba fahren vielleicht auch oder fliegen auch nach Miami, spielen da noch ein bisschen weiter. Aber das 3 Vereinslegenden des FC Barcelona, die ja in der größten, wichtigsten, sportlich besten Ära Barca-Stars da so viel gewonnen haben, binnen einer Saison jeweils bei Barca aufhören, ist natürlich ein riesiger Umbruch und ist was ganz, ganz Spezielles natürlich. Und dass dann, dass auch noch in der Saison es in der Saison endlich mal wieder Meister werden nach vielen sportlich schweren Jahren. Und eben in der Saison, in dem ja das Camp Nou verabschiedet wird, vorerst wird ja auch modernisiert. Barca wird ja für ein Jahr, wahrscheinlich eineinhalb Jahre umziehen ins Olympiastadion auf dem Montjuic. Wird dann nicht im Camp Nou spielen, während das modernisiert wird. Also dass da so ein Ende einer Ära, wenn man so will, wenn man das Stadion so ein bisschen mit reinnehmen will, logisch, dass das so stattfindet in der Saison, ist so, dass die Story schlechthin, nicht nur aus Barca-Sicht, sondern ich glaube irgendwie auch ein bisschen aus der Liga-Sicht, denn in der Liga-Saison, sportlich hat die nicht so viel geboten, so ehrlich muss man sein. Der Meistertitel war klar, war verdient, aber jetzt auch nicht prickelnd besonders. Es gab keinen Meisterschaftskampf, es gab kein richtiges Rennen um die Champions League Ränge. Es war klar, wer nach Europa kommt. Nur der Abstiegskampf war spannend, aber eben auf sehr biederem Niveau. Und auch da nicht mal annähernd so dramatisch, wie man es erwarten hätte können, nachdem sechs Vereine am letzten Spieltag absteigen konnten, gab es trotzdem nicht dieses virtuelle, in der Minute sind die abgestiegen und in der die. Also irgendwie sportlich war das nicht so eine erinnerungswürdige Saison, fand ich. Sehr, sehr überschaubar. Und deswegen verbleibe ich mit diesem Abschied der drei Barca-Ikonen inklusive dem ikonischen Stadion des FC Barcelona.
Abschied ist auch bei mir irgendwo das Stichwort, auch wenn natürlich La Liga hatte hier und da ihre Highlights, ob das der Villas Europa League Sieg war oder auch Rayo und Girona denken offensiv, sind irgendwo teilweise spektakulär spielende Teams. Bei mir ist das Thema Abschied, was jetzt auch am letzten Spieltag nochmal sehr emotional, sehr besonders war, verbunden mit einem Rekord. Da geht es um Joaquín, denn La Liga hat einen neuen Rekordspieler. Joaquín steht jetzt bei 622 Pflichtspielen in La Liga, also für drei verschiedene Vereine. Er hat damit Andoni Subisaredda gleichgestellt, der ist damals auch auf 622 gekommen. Und nicht nur die Art und Weise des Abschieds, wie das schon vor dem Anstoß, dem letzten Spieltag emotional wurde. Selbst dann, zweite Halbzeit begonnen, da gab es auch nochmal Applausen. Joaquín stand mit feuchten Augen auf dem Platz, also der hat dann auch natürlich schon gespielt. Das super emotional, hat direkt ein paar Tage danach sein Abschiedsspiel bekommen, wo auch etliche Legenden um Raúl González und so weiter dabei waren. Also, so könnte es sein, so emotional, dass es dann auch eben La Liga, dass er auch ganz Spanien mitgefiebert hat, dass er überhaupt noch diesen Rekord erreicht. Ihm haben noch so diese, an den letzten acht Spieltagen hätte er siebenmal eingesetzt werden müssen und war teilweise auch noch verletzt, angeschlagen, wurde eingewechselt, aber ja, da geht jetzt eben auch ein ganz besonderer Name, der 2001 debütiert war in La Liga und irgendwie tausend Profi-Spiele in diversen Wettbewerben später hat er das noch gewonnen. Natürlich letztes Jahr sein Highlight Copa del Rey gewonnen mit Bettys, damals hat man schon gedacht, hörte auf, nee, er hat noch ein Jahr dran gesetzt, jetzt wird er im Juli 42, ist da ein ganz ulkiger, lustiger, cooler Typ, eine absolute Marke, wo La Liga so gesehen einen großen Typen verlieren wird als Spieler, aber ein Joaquín-Hashtag mittlerweile Joaquín wird da schon irgendwie immer noch weiter erhalten bleiben im spanischen Fußball.
Und Stichwort Abschied, wir hatten jetzt drei Bass-Ikonen, die La Liga-Ikone Joaquín und Karim Benzema hat sich auch verabschiedet. Also binnen einer Saison fünf große Abschiede. Man kann jetzt natürlich auch das Negativs binden, so Ausverkauf in La Liga oder die glorreiche Zeit neigt sich zum Ende, es gibt den Umbruch. Auch das passt ja irgendwie zu La Liga.
Und es gab doch noch, ich habe den Namen leider gerade vergessen, aber einen ganz bekannten Schiedsrichter, der auch international sehr...
Der Olaros, natürlich.
Genau, genau, Olaros, danke.
Der, der, die, die sechste große Ikone, die sich verabschiedet hat, ja. Wobei der ein bisschen streitbarer war als die... Ich wollte es nicht so böse sagen. Der hat gerade seine Karriere beendet, ja.
Aber wenigstens hat er es geräuschlos und unauffällig gemacht, indem er durch einen von Spielern gebildet ist, spaliert zu seiner Familie gegangen ist.
Im Moment, aber das macht man in Spanien so, dass er in Spanien ist.
Ich habe nur ein Video gesehen, und habe gesehen, dass allein das Video 6 Minuten gedauert hat. Da dachte ich mir, wie lange braucht der für diesen Weg? Das ist wieder die deutsche Kälte, Max. Ja, ja, ich sehe schon. Aber natürlich bin nicht ich schuld, sondern die Bundesliga. Die hat mich einfach emotional kaputt gemacht. Können wir uns darauf einigen. Okay, sorry, dann nehme ich das zurück. Aber Laos hat auch noch aufgehört. Das wollte ich noch mit reinwerfen.
Der wurde aufgehört, der wurde zum Abgang gedrängt. Das gibt ja nicht diese Altersregelung, dass er sagt, der ist jetzt 46, muss aufhören. Nein, La Liga hatte auf gut Deutsch die Schnauze voll von seinen extravaganten Leistungen. Was er dabei bei der WM gezeigt hat, bei was war es, Argentinien, glaube ich, Holland, mit seinen 16 gelben Karten. Und ja, der Spieleitung, die das Spiel kaputt gemacht hat, das hat er auch in Spanien gezeigt. Beim Barcelona-Durby zum Beispiel, da gab es auch 14 oder 15 gelbe Karten teilweise. Absolut lächerliche gelbe Karten für nichts.
Er musste halt immer Protagonist sein.
Genau, und der Spieler wollte nur was sagen, und dann gab es schon Geld. Und La Liga hatte auf gut Deutsch da die Schnauze voll, und das hat ihm gereicht. Die Leistungen haben auch nicht mehr gestimmt. Deswegen haben sie ihn rausgeworfen auf gut Deutsch. Aber er wollte die Karriere nicht beenden, sondern sie wurde für ihn beendet.
Spanisch spät abends aus dem eigenen Klemerstuhl.
Hoffentlich kann er Interpunktion besser. Und kürzt nicht alles ab. Das wäre doch ganz gut zu wissen. Aber gut, Laus, dann haben wir den auch noch genannt. Christian, Mario, was ist noch eine Erinnerung, die ihr mit der Serie A-Saison verbindet?
Ja, klar. Beim Thema Abschiede sind klar der Ibra-Abschied am letzten Spieltag. Ganz interessant, da wusste anscheinend niemand davon. Nicht mal bei Milan. Also es stand im Raum, dass da ein Milan-Abschied bekannt gibt. Aber niemand wusste davor, dass da seine Karriere beenden wird. Also hat er auch da nochmal auf Ibra gemacht. Klar, ein besonderer Moment, aber für mich, ich komme nochmal zurück, für mich ist es trotzdem Napoli. Die ganze Geschichte Napoli, einfach sich die Bilder anschauen aus Neapel in den letzten Wochen. Ich kann nur jedem dazu raten, für mich so das emotionalste Bild war, als Neapel in Uli den Meister geworden ist. Das Feuerwerk in der Nacht über Neapel. Da ist Silvester dagegen ein Witz. Da gibt es Drohnenaufnahmen, kann ich jedem nur raten. Geht mal auf YouTube rein. Was da in der Stadt los war, das war gegen 23 Uhr, war es dann sozusagen mathematisch. Also allein dieses Bild wird für mich immer bleiben, was den Fußball betrifft. Und die letzte kleine Geschichte dazu. Als klar war, dass Spalletti, als dieses Wabern, ja, bleibt er, geht er, er sagt endlich, was Sache ist. Das war die Pressekonferenz vor einem der letzten Spiele, die hat eine halbe Stunde gedauert. Ich habe mir die zweimal angeschaut, weil die war so emotional und so speziell. Und am Ende dieser Pressekonferenz, wo so viel probiert wurde, ihm raus, ja, was ist denn jetzt Sache? Und er hat immer gesagt, hey, das muss der Präsident sagen, für mich ist alles klar, wir haben das untereinander besprochen. Und irgendwie die vorletzte Frage, man hat den Journalisten leider nicht gesehen, aber ich würde mal sagen, vom Ton her war es ein älterer Journalist, also einer, der schon sehr lange dabei war. Und der meinte dann, Herr Spalletti hat angefangen mit, Sie wissen schon, dass Sie für immer eben in dieser Stadt, Sie sind jetzt der König dieser Stadt, Sie werden hier immer, auch wenn Sie jetzt nicht mehr da sind, Sie werden hier immer sozusagen einreiten als der König. Wir sind Ihnen für ewig dankbar. Ich habe eine Frage an Sie. Können Sie uns garantieren, dass Sie nicht zur Juwe gehen? Das hat alles so wunderbar auf den Punkt gebracht. Da wurde dann auch im Pressekonferenzraum leicht gelacht. Aber das war auch ehrlich gemeint. Weil das Schlimmste, was eben passieren könnte, wenn dieser Geniale aus Napoli, Spalletti, jetzt irgendwann noch zur Juwe geht, gedacht, war es doch logisch jetzt gleich im Sommer. Spalletti hat sich auch rausgewundert und gesagt, ich muss erstmal alles schauen, dass ich die nächsten Tage organisiert bekomme, geschweige denn, was danach kommt. Aber ich finde, es ist eine kleine Geschichte, die zeigt, wie speziell der Fußballstandort Neapel ist und wie sehr das da gelebt wird.
Mario?
Eine kleine persönliche Sache. Der Stadionbesuch in Florenz erst kürzlich war toll, weil da auch so wirklich, Christian hat es vorhin mal gesagt, Frauen, Kinder, Alt, Jung, also alles sicher, alles entspannt, alles friedlich, zahlt halt nicht drauf ein, wenn man sagt, aber kann man da mit Kindern ins Stadion gehen? Ich habe seit zwei Wochen Ohrwurm von der Fiorentina-Hymne. Also nicht anhören, wenn ihr keinen Bock auf Ohrwürmer habt. Und darüber hinaus natürlich auch Napoli und auch das schon auch mit begleiten zu dürfen, Hashtag Love my Job so, aber das Juwespiel mit Christian gemacht und dann vielleicht das, was wirklich am präsentesten ist, ist auch da der 38. Spieltag mit Pokalübergabe und da der Abschied von Fabio Quarella in der Stadt, wo er auch aus der Region kommt, wo er auch gespielt hat, seine vermutlich schwerste Phase des Lebens gehabt hat, wo er auch von Stalker, seine Familie bedrängt wurde, wusste man damals alles nicht. Kann man mal googeln und lesen, gibt es viel interessantes Material dazu, wo er dann wirklich zur Juve gegangen ist, weil er in Napoli nicht mehr leben konnte. Das ist ihm damals sehr übel genommen worden und erst, als das später rausgekommen ist, hat sich das alles gelöst. Und auch für ihn hat sich dann was gelöst. Auf einmal hat er nochmal aufgezockt und dann wird er da. Klar, leider samst steigt ab. Er verabschiedet sich aus der Serie A eingültig und wird ausgewechselt im fremden Stadion als Spieler der Gastmannschaft. Spiel unterbrochen, alle haben gutes Gespür dafür gehabt. Alle Napolispieler, ob auf dem Feld oder auf der Bank, kamen ihnen im Abend alle eigenen Spieler und dann ist eine Auswechslung vom Stadionsprecher mit die Nummer 27, Fabio und das ganze Stadion. Das war krass und ein großartiger Spieler. Das an dem Tag, wo Napoli dann da den Pokal bekommt und irgendwie, das hat auch ein bisschen kitschig, aber das bleibt auf jeden Fall hängen.
Ja, wie es Mario sagt, wir durften das ja auch begleiten. Das war wirklich Gänsehaut, das hat mehrere Minuten gedauert. Und ich finde, das ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, wie es in Italien, ich glaube, in Spanien wird das ja auch gelebt, wie gut das Gespür ist für solche Momente. Also wirklich, wie das da inszeniert, finde ich das falsche Wort, weil es war eben nicht inszeniert, es war voller Emotionen. Und wie Mario es sagt, allein, dass da der Stadionssprecher der gegnerischen Mannschaft seinen Namen sozusagen und das ganze Stadion ruft ihn aus, er, der da aus der Region kommt. Also das war wirklich krass und genau der richtige Rahmen, finde ich. Und das finde ich beeindruckend, wie gerade. Ich finde, das sind Spanien und Italien ganz oft ein gutes Beispiel dafür. Ja, wie gut dann diese Momente, diese so großen Spiele oder besonderen Momente auch eingebettet werden von allen Beteiligten. In Italien, der Rossi Totti, kann man da zurückdenken. Da gibt es viele Geschichten, da gibt es in Spanien auch viele. Das ist wirklich jedes Mal Gänsehaut pur.
Sieben Spieltage vor Schluss hat er mit Betis im Camp Nou gespielt. Ich war im Camp Nou. Als er eingewechselt wurde, hat ihm das Camp Nou applaudiert. Sieben Spieltage vor Schluss, da hatte er den Rekord noch gar nicht. Aber man wusste, das ist eine Abschiedstour. Da geht ein ganz, ganz großer Spieler, eine absolute Legende. Und das Camp Nou hat ihm applaudiert. Da hat man schon ein Gespür für, glaube ich, auch in Spanien.
Und bei absoluten Legenden sind wir ja bei euch auch wieder gelandet. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Nicht nur für diese Sendung, sondern für die gesamte Saison. Es hat unglaublich Spaß gemacht. Ich finde, dass das ganze Format noch mal einen richtigen Schritt gemacht hat. Die Rückmeldungen dazu sind ja auch ausnahmslos positiv. Deswegen ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Mario Rieker, an Christian Bernhard, an Fabian Pakulat, Nils Kern und an Alex Truica. Danke euch fünf, dass ihr jetzt hier mit dabei wart. Und wir grüßen natürlich Mario Seucke in Abwesenheit, der auch sehr gerne dabei gewesen wäre, der natürlich auch bei allem, was ich gesagt habe, mit gemeint war. Auch bei der Legende.
Sehr gerne.
Schönen Sommer.
Und wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit der Premier League und der Ligue 1. Hoffentlich zumindest. Jetzt spreche ich mit Alexis Menuge und Uli Hebel über die Ligue 1 und die Premier League. Wer hätte jemals daran gezweifelt, dass das klappt? Hallo Alexis, schön, dass du hier bist. Und quasi frisch aus dem Champions-League-Final-Stadion. Wir haben ihn im Intro noch gehört. Uli Hebel, hallo Uli.
Grüß dich, Last Dance, ich freue mich.
Ist das jetzt für dich der Last Dance nach dieser langen Saison?
Eine Sache habe ich dann gleich im Anschluss noch.
Aber absolut. Ich meine, Alexis wird es ja wahrscheinlich verfolgt haben. Wir haben dir alle zugehört beim Champions-League-Finale. Lass uns direkt damit starten. City hat es endlich geschafft. Das wird jetzt niemandem mehr überraschen. Wie war es dann für dich, das zu kommentieren? Und welchen Eindruck haben denn beide Teams auf dich gemacht?
Also die Gefühlsdoselei nehme ich mal vorweg, damit wir uns dann aufs Inhaltliche konzentrieren können. War, vielleicht wissen das einige Hörerinnen und Hörer von dir auch, war immer mein ganz großes Berufslebensziel. Da habe ich jetzt wirklich drei, vier Jahre lang obsessiv darauf hingearbeitet, umso schöner, dass ich das jetzt bekommen habe, dieses Spiel. Und der ganze Aufenthalt eigentlich so in etwa lief, wie ich es mir gewünscht habe. Und ich glaube, das Spiel war jetzt nicht der Wahnsinn, aber das ist normal bei einem Endspiel. Und ich finde, Inter hat es 20 Minuten lang ausgezeichnet gemacht, wirklich genauso wie man gegen Manchester City spielen muss. Und dann, der Reihe nach, hat man gemerkt, dass eine gewisse Finalnervosität bei City hat verfliegen können, die dann etwas mehr zu ihrem Spiel gefunden haben. Und ich meine, am Ende, so ehrlich muss man ja dann schon sein. Das ist ja dann das große Thema, was so oben drüber schwebt. Die Mittelherkunft, das kann ja auch verstehen, dass man das macht, habe ich ja auch dann versucht, anklingen zu lassen im Spiel. Aber alles in allem, wenn man sich jetzt mal sportlich das anschaut, dann hat schon das Team gewonnen. Das ist ganz klar, dass es hätte gewinnen sollen in der Saison, in der sie einfach einmal mehr gezeigt haben, dass sie es verstehen, wie es geht.
Du hast in deinem Kommentar gesagt, direkt nach dem Schlusspfiff, wir leben jetzt offiziell in der Ära der Sky Blues. Glaubst du, dass das der Beginn von noch mehr Titten sein könnte? Jetzt, wo der Erste geschafft ist?
Ja, glaube ich. Die nationale Dominanz ist ja ohnehin nicht mehr wegzuwischen. Das in dieser so komplizierten Liga, fünf Jahre von sechs möglichen, die Meisterschaft geholt. In Pokalwettbewerben sind sie nicht mehr ganz so extrem dominant gewesen die letzten Jahre. Ich glaube, das war durchaus auch ein bisschen mit eingeplant. Ich hatte das Gefühl, das hat man ja auch in den ersten 20 Minuten gemerkt in dem Finale, dass da irgendwie ein psychologischer Keil im Kopf liegt und nicht so sehr was Sportliches. Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass die Truppe jetzt auch gelernt hat, okay, ja, so geht's. Guardiola, über den habe ich ja sowieso wenig Zweifel. Ich kann mir schon durchaus vorstellen, dass die nächstes Jahr auch wieder mit dabei sind. So ehrlich muss man auch sein, wenn man sich das Spiel anschaut. Ich habe dann auch nochmal mir alles links und rechts angeguckt und Christian Bernhard hat mich auf einen ganz interessanten Fakt gestoßen. Ein paar Stunden bevor ich mit ihm telefoniert habe zum Finale, habe ich mir bei City immer gedacht, als ich die Spieleetiketten geschrieben habe, oh, da ist er war.
Der ist schon 29.
Also Geburtstag hatte, oh, der ist schon 29. Und der hatte Geburtstag, der ist 33. Und dann hat Christian mir gesagt, gönn dir mal den Spaß und berechne mal die Startformationen von Inter, bei denen es ja immer heißt, sind so alt, und Manchester City. Hätte nicht Jacob gespielt, sondern Lukaku, also hat das mir dann richtig hingerechnet, dann wären die im Altersschnitt gleich gewesen. Ich will sagen, City muss schon langsam, aber sicher auch verjüngen. Die sind jetzt alle im aller, allerbesten Alter, aber wir wissen ganz schnell, wie schnell das gehen kann, dass die dann eins drüber sind. Das heißt, das ist das, was ich mir jetzt angucke, aber das ist wieder bei der Mittelherkunft. Wahrscheinlich wird es jetzt nicht so problematisch sein, den Kader auch bürgerlich zu verjüngen.
Das Geld dafür wird vorhanden sein. Vielleicht träumt gerade Alexis davon, was hätte sein können, wenn PSG mal diesen psychologischen Bann des Finals gebrochen hätte. Dann könnten wir jetzt vielleicht auch in der Ära von PSG leben. Da kämen die Mittel woanders her, und es wären aber genauso viele. Ist es nicht wunderbar?
Ja, vielleicht war das auch dieses Finale, dieser Triumph von City, insbesondere für die Verantwortlichen von Paris Saint-Germain, dass sie endlich mal feststellen, dass nach wie vor kein Spieler über den Verein stehen darf. Das kapieren sie schon langsam, scheinbar. Und dass man eine eingeschworene Einheit auf dem Platz haben sollte und auch viel Geduld. Weil City hat es auch nicht von heute an morgen geschafft. Sieben Jahre Guardiola, schon eine lange Zeit, aber es hat sich gelohnt. Man war auch vorher einmal im Finale, immer wieder im Halbfinale. Aber auch an absolute Legendenmannschaften wie Lyon gescheitert oder Porto, glaube ich. Also auf jeden Fall zu früh und gegen Mannschaften, die in der Champions League eigentlich nie so weit kommen. Und die Verantwortlichen von City waren immer sehr geduldig mit Guardiola. Mit diesem Projekt haben auch Guardiola frei herangelassen. In Paris ist der Trainer gebunden oder wird komplett im Stich gelassen. Und dann in Bosnien, die öfters in Doha als in Paris sind. Und das ist ein ganz anderes noch Fast-Konzept, hätte ich schon gesagt. Aber wie gesagt, vielleicht war dieser Triumph von City für PSG auch etwas Gutes im Hinblick auf die Zukunft mittel- und langfristig. Weil Paris wird auch nächste Saison nicht in der Champions League im Finale stehen.
Ach ja, ja und all die Nebengeräusche dazu, die kennen ja alle. Und wenn man sich anguckt, was gerade Saudi-Arabien macht, um sich im Sport generell und auch im Fußball zu positionieren. Also wir leben einfach in der Zeit des Sportswashings und der Multiclub-Ownership. Wird hier noch oft genug im Rasenfang angesprochen werden, müssen wir jetzt nicht wieder alles durchdiskutieren. Aber kann es sein, Uli, dass wir nicht nur in der Ära der Sky Blues leben, sondern dass wir gerade auch eine absolute Hochphase der Premier League auch europäisch erleben? Denn wir haben mit West Ham ja noch einen weiteren Titelträger, der von dort kommt.
Ja, ich glaube, diese WM-Pause, die hat in der Saison ganz, ganz viel zum Guten gewendet für die englischen Teams. War ja die große Frage. Was würde das mit allen machen und was würde das insbesondere mit zum Beispiel England machen, die zwar relativ schnell wieder angesetzt haben nach der WM mit Spielen, aber durch diese kurze Pause zumindest den Vorteil hatten, dass sie die gleiche Ausgangslage mehr oder minder haben wie die anderen. Und das, glaube ich, hat denen dieses Jahr wahnsinnig gut getan. Normalerweise sind sie ja immer klar im Nachteil, was gespielte Spiele und vor allen Dingen absolvierte Urlaubstage betrifft. Und in dem Fall sind sie relativ gleich auf gewesen. Gut, das Einzige, was vielleicht noch dagegen spricht, ist, dass mit dem Tod der Queen da ja wirklich eineinhalb Wochen verloren wurden mitten drin. Aber wie komme ich zu dieser These, wenn ich mir nämlich angucke, wie die Premier Leagueisten reingestartet sind nach der nach der WM, dann war das so, dass die meisten relativ normal performt haben, drei Wochen lang, und dann kam das Loch, was für die Allermeisten normal im April kommt. Und das heißt, das lief für sie von der zeitlichen Ansetzung her ganz gut. Und dann war eben nochmal West Ham auch mit dabei und hat auch einen europäischen Titel holen können, sodass wir nächstes Jahr acht, Wahnsinn, fast die Hälfte der Liga, acht Teilnehmer in europäischen Wettbewerben haben. Ich bin aber gespannt, und das glaube ich gar nicht, dass ich das so durchziehen kann. Also auch da, die eine Sache liegt ja auf der Hand. Das Geld ist da, die Kader breit genug zu machen. Und das haben alle Teams gemacht. Und davon profitiert man irgendwann einmal, auch wenn Citys Kader so breit gar nicht ist, weil sie am Ende 22 Spieler eingesetzt haben.
Und ehrlich gesagt haben sie eigentlich nur mit 14 gespielt.
Die ganze Saison.
Vielleicht 15, wenn ich Ortega noch mit dazuzähle.
Aber im Wesentlichen haben da ja einige gar nicht gespielt. Aber bei West Ham ist es ein wesentlicher Unterschied. Das ist, glaube ich, das Team, an dem man es am besten festmachen kann. In den letzten zwei Jahren jeweils hinten raus eingebrochen. Halbfinale gegen Frankfurt, wo man schon gemerkt hat, so ganz haut es nicht mehr hin.
Und auch in der Liga nochmal verloren.
Im Jahr davor war es sogar noch ein bisschen dramatischer. Und in dem Jahr sind sie zum Schluss sogar nochmal mit einem Peak gekommen. Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt keine körperliche Sache, sondern ich tippe mal, eine Kopfsache gewesen.
Acht Europapokal-Teilnehmer aus der Premier League. Also das ist wirklich faszinierend und auch möglich überhaupt erst durch die drei Wettbewerbe und so, wie die UEFA das aufgeteilt hat. Aber das ist ja das Ziel. Und jetzt müssen wir uns alle mit der Premier League messen. Aber der laufen wir ja sowieso schon die ganze Zeit hinterher. Dann lasst uns mal kurz auf die Meister in beiden Ligen blicken. Alexis, also PSG ist Meister geworden. Am Ende unglaublich knapp eigentlich. Also es ist natürlich nur die Momentaufnahme, aber ein Punkt Vorsprung vor Lance. Und wieder sehr, sehr viele Diskussionen. der jetzt angeblich schon länger bekannt gegeben hätte, dass er seinen Vertrag nicht verlängern wird bei PSG. Sehr viele Diskussionen. Messi wurde bei der Meisterfeier ausgeboot. Also es ist wieder alles Mögliche los bei PSG. Wie würdest du denn jetzt diese Saison zusammenfassen?
Ich glaube schon, dass es, obwohl man Meister wurde und dadurch auch zum Rekordmeister aufgestiegen ist, denn mit elf Meistertiteln ist man an St. Etienne vorbeigezogen. Trotzdem war es die schlechteste Saison PSG seit USA eingestiegen ist, vor zwölf Jahren. Pokalfrüh ausgeschieden, in der Champions League erneut im Athletfinale, zum vierten Mal in den letzten sechs Jahren. Und in der Meisterschaft hast du das erwähnt, war Meister geworden, aber nur mit einem mikrigen Punkt Vorsprung auf Lanze, nur am vorletzten Spieltag, die Krönung perfekt gemacht. Der Titel wurde auch nicht wirklich gefeiert, weil da gibt es einfach zu viele Dissonanzen in der Kabine, zu viele Baustellen überall im Verein und es gab auch zwei PSG in dieser Saison. Ich glaube schon, dass es der Verein war, der am meisten unter der WM gelitten hat. Denn vor der WM war PSG ungeschlagen, alle drei Wettbewerben, auch wenn man gemerkt hat, je näher die WM rückt, desto schlechter wird auch das Spiel an sich, die Spielweise. Die Rückrunde war einfach katastrophal. Ich glaube sieben in der Lage, allein in der Ligue 1, zehn Wettbewerbs übergreifend, gegen Bayern zweimal verloren, kein Tor erzielt bei diesem Kader. Und ein Trainer, der einfach nicht auf der Höhe war. Aber das hätte man schon vor der Saison wissen sollen. Einer, der noch nie mit einer solchen Kabine gearbeitet hatte, in seiner Karriere nur sechs Spiele in der Champions League beschritten hatte, darunter fünf Niederlagen, der kaum Fremdsprachen kann. In dieser Kabine wird fast nur Spanisch oder Englisch gesprochen. Man hat zum ersten Mal in der Katar-Geschichte bei PSG bei der Trainerwahl dem Sportdirektor die Entscheidung gelassen. Luis Campos, der seinen Kumpel-Kartier geholt hat, was natürlich im Nachhinein ein Fehler war. Jetzt ist man gespannt, wen man als Trainer holt und wer vor dem entscheidet. Scheinbar wird das wieder Doha sein oder Katar, mit dem Altani, also der Oberchef dort. Aber zu dieser Saison 22, 23 kann man nur den Kopf schütteln, auch die Fans haben sich immer mehr distanziert von dem Verein. Mit Messi hat es von A bis Z nicht geklappt, menschlich, sportlich, was schon besser. Aber man hat Messi abgelehnt, weil er sich nie für PSG interessiert hat, hat nie für PSG gekämpft, hat sich auch nie zu PSG wirklich bekennt, hat nie den Fans zugewunken und so weiter. Und das hat einfach gar nicht geklappt. Und es ist schon schade, was da alles abläuft. Man sieht, was da vor allem für finanzielle Ressourcen entstehen. Aber wie gesagt, vielleicht werden die Verantwortlichen, es ist auch die letzte Chance, die Lehren zu ziehen. Man hat schon Messi gehen lassen. Papi hast du schon angesprochen. Und man versucht mit aller Macht auch, Neymar loszukriegen. Nur er hat noch ein 4-Jahres-Vertrag. Bei 36 Netto im Jahr sind das 240 Millionen brutto. Und wer zahlt das außer Saudi-Arabien? Man bettelt, dass Saudi-Arabien in ein fantastisches Angebot unterbreitet, so dass Neymar auch geht. Dann kann man vielleicht nicht mehr so viele klangvolle Namen auf dem Platz haben. Dafür aber eine eingeschworene Truppe, eine Mannschaft. Dann hat man wahrscheinlich das Potenzial, mit besseren Chancen, die Tjermisig besser abzuschneiden und auch in der Liga ein bisschen konstanter aufzutreten mit einer schöneren, attraktiveren Spielweise.
Das ist ja wirklich ein Treppenwitz. Da gehen die ganzen Staaten rein in den Fußball, um loszukommen von ihrer Abhängigkeit von Öl und Gas und um sich geopolitisch auf die Landkarte zu bringen. Und dann hofft dann in dem Fall Katar darauf, dass Saudi-Arabien das Land, vor dem man sich geopolitisch schützen musste, weil die Blockade ja von Saudi-Arabien damals ausging, dass es vielleicht in dem Fall dann hilft, dass die jetzt auch in den Sport reingehen. Ach, ist es nicht wunderbar, mit welchen Themen man sich beschäftigen muss. So ist also die Lage bei PSG und bei City. Ich meine, wir haben schon kurz draufgeblickt, Uli aber ja eher so aus der Champions League-Trippelbrille. Jetzt hatten wir ja mal einen anderen Meisterschaftskampf mit Arsenal in dieser abgelaufenen Saison. Siehst du begründeten Anlass zur Hoffnung, dass diese Dominanz von City jetzt wirklich mal nicht nur herausgefordert wird, sondern vielleicht auch dann doch von anderen aus den berühmten Top 6 oder vielleicht sind es eher Top 5 gerade und das mit Newcastle Neuer mit dabei herausgefordert wird in den nächsten Jahren?
Vorneweg, es wird so bleiben, dass ein englischer Meister zwei Dinge für sich laufen haben muss. Zum einen, dass er überperformt und zum anderen, dass Manchester City unterperformt. Die zwei Dinge müssen, glaube ich, einhergehend miteinander. So wird es auch in Zukunft bleiben. Erstmal aber, und das ist das Positive, Arsenal hat gezeigt, dass sie dabei sein können. Ich glaube, auch die sind gekommen, um zu bleiben. Das sieht strukturell so gut aus. Die haben einen erstaunlichen Trainer. Also Guardiola hat sich sozusagen seinen größten Konkurrenten in der diesjährigen Liga-Saison selbst ausgebildet, was einfach klar dafür spricht, dass der noch mal oben drüber steht, aber Arsenal ist strukturell gut genug aufgestellt. Die brauchen ein, zwei Stellschrauben zu drehen. Dann glaube ich, haben die auch ihre Problemchen nochmal angegangen. All die, die jetzt dabei waren, sind ein Jahr älter geworden, was für so eine junge Mannschaft wahnsinnig wichtig ist. Ein Jahr erfahrener geworden, haben jetzt schon die erste Niederlage verkraften müssen, werden hoffentlich daraus gestärkt hervorgehen. Habe ich auch schon mal bei dir hier gesagt, man darf nie vergessen, diese Truppe, die da City so lange wirklich gefordert hat, die hat noch nicht ein Champions-League-Spiel zusammen absolviert. Das wird auch dazukommen in der nächsten Saison. Das heißt, ich glaube fest an Arsenal, ob die jetzt nächste Meister werden. Gerade deswegen glaube ich, dass die stark sein können und die sind clever genug, sich auch zu verbreitern, weil das das große Problem war. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, was, das kann ja nicht jetzt in dieser Saison einfach so passieren. Das sind ja Dinge, die müssen aus meiner Sicht wachsen, organisch wachsen. Du wirst mal mit einem Transfer vielleicht daneben greifen. Das ist normal, dass dann ein Team den wieder ausspuckt oder vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht dann irgendwann im zweiten Jahr integriert etc. Das war ja bei City auch so. Also wie viel Ausschuss war da dabei auf der Suche nach dem Außenverteidigern zum Beispiel. Und ich glaube aber, dass diese Mehrfachbelastung, dass sozusagen, dass es selbstverständlicher wird für Arsenal, dass das dazu führt, dass die mit dabei bleiben. Ich glaube auch nach wie vor ganz fest daran, einen Transfer haben sie ja schon gemacht in McAllister, dass Liverpool noch einen weiteren Transfer davon entfernt ist, wieder absolut dabei zu sein. Das Thema Umstellung jetzt im letzten Saisondrittel hat mir außerordentlich gut gefallen. Ich habe immer geschimpft, dass Klopp nicht anpasst. Hat er jetzt getan. Das sieht gut aus. Ich glaube, damit sind auf einen Schlag zwei, drei Schwächen dieser Truppe raus. Die haben sehr gut eingekauft, schon im letzten Winter jetzt. Es werden Dinge sein, die sich absolut zum Besseren hin verändern. Und dann gibt es ja noch dieses eine große Enigma, das theoretisch den stärksten Kader von allen wahrscheinlich sogar hat. In jedem Fall die stärksten Verträge. Und wir wissen ja nicht, was bei Chelsea noch passiert. In der Theorie ist das eine absurd talentierte Truppe. Wenn Bocetino das irgendwie zusammenkriegt und wenn die sich da untereinander alle irgendwie so verständigen, dass nicht permanent einer der Besitzer in den Raum kommt, kurz bevor die Dinge abgeschlossen sind und sagt, das machen wir jetzt ganz anders, weil ich das gerade lustig finde, dann müssten die eigentlich auch ganz oben mit dabei sein. Also das sind die vier Teams, die ich habe, mit schon Abstufungen nach City, aber es wird dabei bleiben, das muss eine grandiose Saison sein. Und die hat ja Arsenal zu drei Vierteln gespielt, vielleicht sogar sieben Achteln gespielt, damit es wirklich so eng ist, wie es dann wenigstens zeitweise schien, eng zu sein.
Unter dem Strich war es ja dann doch wieder relativ deutlich. Und kurz zur Einordnung, falls ihr euch gefragt habt, wo ist jetzt eigentlich Chelsea gelandet am Ende der Saison? Rang zwölf. Ich meine, sie werden keine Mehrfachbelastung haben. Dann haben wir ja aber unter den Champions-League-Teilnehmern, also City und Arsenal sind klar und dann United und Newcastle haben es noch geschafft. Liverpool und Brighton sind dann in die Europa League gelandet und Aston Villa, Europa Conference League plus ja noch West Ham mit dazu. Was ist denn so zu den anderen Europapokal-Teilnehmern zu sagen? Gerade bei United zum Beispiel haben wir ja auch eine Saison. Also das wäre nicht zu jedem Zeitpunkt der Saison vorhersehbar gewesen, dass die es schaffen, sich wieder für die Champions League zu qualifizieren.
Ne, muss man mal überlegen, was in dieser Saison alles passiert. Die ganze Ronaldo-Nummer war alles in dieser Spielzeit. Das habe ich schon fast wieder in die letzte gedrängt, weil es so lang her ist und weil es auch so was von lächerlich war. Ich glaube, dass Manchester United total überperformt hat in der Saison. Die sind nicht so gut, wie sie stehen. Zweimal Pokalfinale, einmal davon sogar gewonnen. Dann Platz 3 in der Liga. Das zeigt mir einfach nur bei all den Baustellen, die die haben, und das sind echt viele. Das sind viele, viele Baustellen. Haben die eine jetzt aber fertiggestellt. Beim Manager.
Das ist ein richtig guter.
Ich glaube, direkt danach lohnt es sich weiterzugehen. Da steckt auch viel Geld drin, aber das ist im besten Fall eine für die Champions League, das ist ja auch immer ein Bemessungsgrundlagenthema, aber eine leicht überdurchschnittliche Truppe mit einigen Schwächen. Und der hat die so hergerichtet, dass die in ganz vielen Spielen die gegnerischen Schwächen bestens aufspielen. Das ist nach wie vor unter dem Strich eine Konter-Truppe, fair enough, und jetzt geht es halt darum, ihm peu à peu weiterhin machen zu lassen, sich verwirklichen zu lassen, so gut es geht. Mir wurde gesagt, so aus Vereinskreisen, es passiert jetzt noch etwas in Richtung Übernahme, aber fürs Erste ist das Transferbudget mal so bei 100 Millionen Euro angesetzt, was nicht so viel ist. Das ist ein Dreiviertel der Stürmer von der Klasse, wie sie ihn eigentlich bräuchten. Dann käme noch etwas dazu, wenn sie Verkäufe tätigen könnten, also McGuire beispielsweise loswerden würden oder andere Gehälter, dass man dann vielleicht nur mal 15 bis 20 Millionen links oder rechts mit dazu machen kann. Aber sie haben einen auslaufenden Vertrag vom Torhüter, sie brauchen einen Stürmer, sie brauchen eigentlich auch einen besser passenden Innenverteidiger. Sie bräuchten unbedingt einen Sechser, der zu Casemiro passt, weil ehrlich gesagt ist es nicht die Lösung, es freht auch nicht, die McTormy-Nicke auch nicht. Ganz seltsame Pärchenbildungen. Jetzt könnte ich noch weitererzählen, das sind nur die absolut akuten Fälle. Ich glaube, dass United auch im nächsten Jahr bestenfalls wieder so sein wird wie in diesem Jahr, weil die einfach noch zu sehr mit Umbauen beschäftigt sein werden. Das ist so die Prognose mal.
Und wird es Newcastle schaffen, sich mit all dem Geld, was man da hat, und all den Spielern dauerhaft in den Top 4 festzusetzen?
Also ich finde das immer erst mal so ein Märchen. Damit möchte ich mal aufräumen. Jetzt will ich die nicht reinwaschen, im Sinne des Sportswashings, aber das, was die bis dato ausgegeben haben, seit Übernahme Saudi-Arabien, ist nicht so viel mehr, als das ein Premier League ist, mit dem Status Newcastles hätte tun können. Ja, das sind schon einiges an Ablösesummen gewesen, die sich jetzt in die Hand genommen haben, aber ein Team, das 5, 6, 7 Jahre lang in der Premier League spielt und diese Fernsehgelder genossen hat, das kann das auch so machen. Zumal sie vorher wahnsinnig wenig getan haben. Ich finde, die sind transfertechnisch, das ist ein großer Grund, warum die da stehen, wo sie stehen, total organisch rangegangen. Die haben sich wirklich bloß Stück für Stück verbessert. Kann natürlich sein, dass sie jetzt durchdrehen mit Champions League und dann sagen, komm, was kostet jeder Neymar? Lass uns mal hier Saudi-Arabien nach Thailand-Wheelside verfrachten. Her mit dem und gibt es noch einen Crazy-Baller, der in Brasilien gerade rumläuft und das Interesse von, weiß ich nicht, Borussia Mönchengladbach auf sich gezogen hat, dann geben wir dem mal 460 Millionen. Kann schon sein, aber für den Moment glaube ich nicht dran. Sondern die verpflichten, sehr, sehr clever. Und das ist der Grund, warum das da so gut funktioniert. Ich glaube auch, dass die nicht weggehen aus dem Top 4. Also das ist einfach ein super gut strukturiertes, trainiertes Team.
Dazu muss man sagen, da laufen ja auch noch die Vorbereitungen, richtig Geld reinlaufen zu lassen. Also jetzt wird der neue Hauptsponsor, kommt jetzt aus Saudi-Arabien. Und das ist ja ganz wichtig hinsichtlich Financial Fair Play. Ob man es einhält, ist letztlich, man sieht es ja in City, egal. Aber man muss den Schein wahren, dass eben die Einnahmen mit den Ausgaben noch in einem Verhältnis stehen. Und das kann man eben über so ein Trikotsponsoring machen, wo man eben dann Geld reinschiebt in den Verein, dass es dann auch wieder rausgeht. Und dann gibt es da halt nur rein zufällig einen Bezug zwischen Trikotsponsor und Investor. Nun ja, das sind die Champions League Teilnehmer in der Premier League. Alexi, wenn wir auf die Ligue 1 gucken, da haben wir natürlich Pégé, dann haben wir Lens und wir haben noch mal Sey in der Qualifikation. Wobei ja gerade Lens einfach eine fantastische Saison gespielt hat, oder?
Es ist nur der achte Budget der Ligue 1. Mit relativ unbekannten Spielern. Aber wie sie als angeschlorene Einheit aufgetreten sind, von ersten Spieltag an bis zum letzten, mit einer wie immer riesen Euphoribum-Stimmung da im Stadt Felix Bolart. Und Lens würde in der Bundesliga mithalten, was das Fan-Potenzial betrifft, weil die auch sehr zahlreich auch bei Auswärtsspielen dabei sind. Im Durchschnitt hast du in Frankreich 5-600 Auswärtsfans, aber mit Lens hast du mindestens 4-5.000. Und das ist schon ein anderes Kaliber. Zweiter völlig verdient. Die waren sehr zufrieden mit diesem Platz, weil sie immer gesagt haben, PSG ist eh nicht einzuholen. Aber wenn du die Saison mit nur einem Punkt Rückstand beendest, dann hast du schon vielleicht eine gewisse Frustration, auch wenn sie nie rausgekommen ist. Nichtsdestotrotz war es wichtig für Lens, definitiv in der Gruppenphase der Champions League zu sein, weil Marseille muss jetzt über zwei Runden. Die letzten Jahre haben die Franzosen in den Playoffs immer gescheitert, insbesondere in Monaco die letzten zwei Jahre, an Donetsk und dann an Eindhoven im letzten Sommer. Marseille, das steht noch von Herrn Herkules Aufgabe, aber noch bei Lens kurz zu bleiben. Dann haben wir auch ein paar Spieler entdeckt, die auch heiß begehrt sind oder werden, mit den österreichischen Nationalverteidigern dann so. Vielleicht der beste Verteidiger, der liegt an, war in dieser Saison Seko Fofana, ein starker Mittelfeldspieler, der sehr gut in die Premier League reinpassen würde. Und natürlich der Lois Openda, der belgische Nationalströmer, der wohl schon bei Leipzig eine Einigung erzielt haben soll, aber Lens will ihn nicht ziehen lassen. Man hat schon drei Angebote von Hasenballsport abgelehnt. Er soll dort eine Lücke schließen, offiziell. Aber Openda ist halt der typische Nummer 9, was der Nr. 9 nicht ist. Openda ist eher eine hängende Spitze und kann auf allen Positionen spielen. Openda ist ein typischer Strafraum- oder Torjäger. Das war schon von den Feinsten. Und vor allem Frank Aels, zum besten Trainer der Liga, zu Recht gewählt worden. Auch er wird heiß begehrt. Auch in der Premier League oder von Olympique Marseille. Aber er soll doch noch eine Saison in Lens bleiben. Und die Frage, Max, ist, kann Lens über den Sommer hinaus diese Achse halten? Beziehungsweise sie auch noch verstärken dazu mit drei, vier Spielern, um mit den neuen Belastungen in der Champions League eine korrekte Figur abzugeben? Man wird ja bei der Auslosung am 31. August in den Top 4 landen und da warten sicherlich drei harte Gegner auf dich. Zum Beispiel können es ja Milan, Real und Bayern werden. Wenn man sich die verschiedenen Töpfe ansieht, das wäre natürlich für Lens ein Traum, ganz klar, weil die eine große Ambition in diesem Wettbewerb haben und dann sechs Festspiele haben. Aber klar, Lens war die Mannschaft der Saison, auch wenn sie nicht Meister wurde. Und Olampid Marseille war eigentlich mehr Frust als Erfolg, weil man muss auch nicht vergessen, in der Champions League-Gruppe Lester geworden, in einer machbaren Gruppe mit einem schwachen Tottenhemd, mit Frankfurt und Sporting, und das in der allerletzten Sekunde von Platz 2 auf Platz 4 runtergerutscht. Im Pokal schmeißt man Peugeot raus und dann verschleitet man an den 2., der nun Drittligisten anzieht, sogar zu Hause im Viertelfinale. In der Liga wollte man unbedingt diese zwei Qualirunden vermeiden. Man hat, glaube ich, vier der letzten fünf Spiele in der Liga verloren. Zum Saisonende hat Igor Tudow, der Trainer, seinen Rücktritt angekündigt. Dann steht OM wie jeden Sommer seit drei Jahren vor einem Scherbenhaufen. Das ist die Politik vom jungen Präsidenten Pablo Longoria. Jedes Jahr einen neuen Trainer und sieben bis acht Spieler wechseln. Ich verstehe nicht wirklich, wohin das führen soll, außer ein bisschen Geld einzunehmen. Aber sportlich betrachtet, das ist schon zu bescheiden für einen Verein, der sehr populär ist. In Frankreich ist er der populärste, noch populärer als PSG. Man weiß nicht wirklich, wohin der Weg führen soll. Man hört immer wieder, und das ist der große Traum, wird dir auch wieder gefallen, dass Saudis da einsteigen und richtig Kohle reinpumpern. Dass man da als in der sportlichen Leitung, die in Zidane die ganz große Markt gibt. Zidane ist ja aus Marseille, deswegen lennt er immer wieder Angebote von PSG ab. Aber das wird auch nicht von heute auf morgen kommen. Deswegen ist man sehr gespannt, wie die neue Saison aussehen wird. Aber mit vielen Fragezeichen und unvorstellbar, dass Marseille auch in der kommenden Saison im Meisterkampf irgendein Wort mitrennen sollte, auch wenn bei PSG auch ein Umbruch ansteht.
Also bei Marseille irgendwie alles wie immer. Wahrscheinlich muss man die Spieler verkaufen, um die Abfindung für die Trainer zu zahlen. So ist wahrscheinlich die Logik. Wenn das eine aufhören würde, dann könnte man sich auch das andere sparen. Und das ist vielleicht noch die Info, dass das nicht untergegangen ist. Also der Danzo, von dem du gesprochen hast, das ist Kevin Danzo, den wir mal bei Augsburg gesehen haben, den wir mal bei Düsseldorf gesehen haben. Der jetzt Teil der besten Abwehr der Liga ist. Und zwar mit weitem Abstand. 29 Gegentreffer nur bei 38 Spielen. Das ist schon... Hätte man vielleicht so nicht kommen sehen. Also ich zumindest nicht.
Ja, er ist auch imponiert durch seine takische Flexibilität. Ob Vierer- oder Dreierkette. Auch wenn er lieber in einer Dreierkette spielt. Ich glaube, Aral Fagnik setzt auch auf ihn mittlerweile bei den Österreichern in der Nationalmannschaft. Leider ist er jetzt verletzt. Wird wohl, glaube ich, ausfallen gegen Belgien und Schweden in den nächsten Tagen in der EM-Quali. Aber ich bin gespannt, ob Lance in der Lage ist, ihn zu halten. Er hat ein konkretes Angebot vom AC Mailand auf dem Tisch liegen. Er hat sich wirklich super entwickelt. Er kann mittlerweile auch schon fließend französisch. Der Streik aus Augsburg nach Lance hat sich doch noch gelohnt, auch wenn es natürlich keine schönen Methoden sind.
Und immer noch erst 24 Jahre alt. Erst im September wird er 25. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Karriere vor der Linse. Dann lassen wir uns noch ganz kurz, Uli, auf der Premier League-Seite noch über die anderen Europapokal-Teilnehmer sprechen. Wir müssen jetzt nicht im Detail alles genau besprechen. Aber ich habe ja die Namen vorhin schon genannt. Liverpool haben natürlich alle mitbekommen, weil da war eben die große Frage, schaffen sie die Champions League? Nein, schaffen sie nicht. Und Brighton war ja so ein bisschen der Liebling hier. Der wurde immer mal wieder so nebenher erwähnt im Rasenfunk, weil die einfach Spaß gemacht haben mit ihrem Spiel und ja auch quasi sehr viel aus ihren Mitteln herausgeholt haben. Was ist zu den restlichen Europapokal-Teilnehmern in Kürze zu sagen?
Es sind ja nur noch zwei, nur noch. Aston Villa nach Unai Emery, der ja mit de facto nach der WM begonnen hat, fantastische Aufholjagd gemacht, hat ein Unai Emery-Team erschaffen. Ist jetzt nicht besonders schön anzusehen, aber sind wieder schwierig zu schlagen. Hat das Beste aus Oli Wotkins rausgeholt und hat jetzt das gepackt, was, glaube ich, niemand mehr gedacht hat, dass möglich sei. Ist auch ein Team, das, glaube ich, da bleibt in der Region. Dann gibt es ja noch West Ham, die sich jetzt nicht so sehr über die Liga qualifiziert hätten, wo es lange nach Abstiegskampf aussah, was aber auch noch zeigt, dass sie in den Jahren zuvor einfach wahnsinnig stark gewesen sind. Und jetzt eigentlich, glaube ich, ungefähr da angekommen, wo sie in der Liga hingehören. Aber ein typisches David Moyes-Team waren und ich hoffe jetzt irgendwann mal für West Ham daraus gelernt haben. Man kann nicht einfach so immer denken, ja, das wird schon passen mit dem Kader. Zumal ja mit Declan Rice möglicherweise jemand gehen wird, der schon für vieles verantwortlich war, was den Klassen halt betrifft.
Ich hoffe mal, dass die Team A für Jüngen und B verstärken an gewissen Positionen, wo einfach hängt. Aber trotzdem muss man noch mal rausheben, ich habe über David Moyes ganz oft geschimpft, ganz, ganz oft geschimpft. Und der Fußball, den er spielen lässt, ist nicht meiner. Wird auch nicht mehr meiner werden. Aber der war jetzt letztes Jahr im Halbfinale, europäisch jetzt sogar im Finale. Und gewonnen sind schon wieder im europäischen Wettbewerb dabei. Das müsste jetzt dann sein das dritte Jahr in Folge, vielleicht sogar das vierte, wenn ich mich ganz täusche. Also das ist wirklich ein Wahnsinnsjob, den der da macht. Und es tut mir sehr leid, David Moyes, dass ich nicht dran geglaubt habe, weil das ist wirklich echt stark, muss man sagen.
Ja, das muss man auch noch dazusagen, wenn man sich Europa-Pokalfinal-Spiele so anguckt. Moyes holt den Titel in der Conference League. Mendeleiba haben wir schon vorhin besprochen, mit Sevilla noch, da war das auch nicht absehbar. Also da gab es ein paar schöne Geschichten auf der Trainerbank. Ich wollte jetzt aber bei Brighton, Huff & Albion gar nicht so drüber rutschen. In der neuen Ted Lesor-Staffel heißt es Huff & Albion. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass wir gegen eine Steuer-, in der Anwaltskanzlei spielen. Guter Gag, wie ich finde. Was ist darüber hinaus noch zu Brighton zu sagen?
Also auch da, wenn man sich überlegt, macht den Erfolg einfach nur noch mal größer, was in dieser Saison alles passiert ist. Es war auch diese Saison, in der Graham Potter gegangen ist als Trainer und alle dachten, oh nein, jetzt stürzen sie ein. Haben Roberto de Zerbi geholt und es war das Beste, was denen hier passiert ist, plus das ganze Geld. Und es ist bei weitem nicht alles, was einem Personal in der Saison gegangen ist. Das ist, dass der Jazz ist de facto aus Brighton zusammengezimmert. Das heißt, die ganze Infrastruktur ist wirklich einmal hart herausgefordert worden und das hat funktioniert. Und dann kam de Zerbi und es hat ein, zwei, drei Wochen gedauert, ehe man sah, oh, okay, das geht in diese Richtung. Wir haben bei Click and Rush zum Beispiel versucht, mal die most improved players zu suchen, also den am meisten verbesserten Spieler. Und im Grunde hätte ich ganz Breiten da hinschreiben können, weil jeder Einzelne einen riesengroßen Schritt gemacht hat. Und die, die schon so gut waren, haben einen kleinen Schritt noch mal gemacht. Es ist erstaunlich, was de Zerbi aus Spielern wie Dank, wie Soli Marge, wie Mitoma, der noch in Belgien gespielt hat letztes Jahr bei Saugeroi gemacht hat. Was der aus, ich weiß nicht, ob ich dem vorgreife, aber der Rookie des Jahres ist Evan Ferguson. Sieht aus wie so eine Kreuzung, eine ganz gefährliche Kreuzung aus Haarland und Wayne Rooney. Weil der so der personifizierte Wille, aber hat auch, hat sowas körperlich total robustes und einnehmendes. Dann hat er einen Torhüter reingestellt mit Stil, der, ja, hat man vielleicht mal bei FIFA oder beim Fußballmanager rumlaufen sehen, aber hatte ich nie auf dem Schirm, dass der irgendwann mal spielen würde. Kommt rein und ist plötzlich ein Riesenfußballer. Und all diese Dinge gemacht, das Team so hingerichtet, dass die wirklich Angst und Schrecken verbreitet haben, zum Teil dann auch wiederum komische Ergebnisse, aber alles in allem De Zerbi für mich so einer meiner persönlichen Darlings. Auch da wieder, Christian wird jetzt hier viel zu oft genannt, aber Christian Bernhard hat mir schon vor Jahren mal gesagt, bei Sassolo turnt einer rum, der ist gut. Und ich habe ihn dann auch angerufen, als De Zerbi kam und gesagt, jetzt kannst du mir mal von De Zerbi endlich erzählen. Dann hat er in höchsten Tönen von dem geschwerben. Ich dachte mir, Sassolo ist das eine, und jetzt schauen wir mal, was bei Brighton geht. Nach zwei Wochen habe ich ihm das erste Mal geschrieben, jetzt verstehe ich, wo du herkommst. Das hat sich bis zum Ende der Saison nicht geändert. Das ist einer meiner absoluten Lieblinge in der Saison gewesen.
Also, die werden wir auch europäisch sehen. Aus der Ligue 1 kommen da noch Ren auf jeden Fall und Lille auch noch mit dazu. Die haben aber auch noch die Plätze getauscht am letzten Spieltag. Das war eine der wenigen Sachen, die noch passiert ist in dieser Saison-Plus-Abstieg. Darüber werden wir gleich noch sprechen, Alexi. Wir haben schon mal über Jonathan David von Lille gesprochen mit 24 Toren, der überragende Stürmer da vorne drin. Bei Rennen ist es ein bisschen breiter verteilt. Auch da gibt es aber eine ganze Reihe von Spielern, die einiges an Toren erzielt haben. Wie haben dir denn jetzt dann die Spielzeiten dieser beiden Teams gefallen? Wir haben ja immer mal wieder so kurz über sie gesprochen.
Ich würde gleich mit dem dritten Team anfangen, der im Europavokal dabei sein darf, Toulouse.
Ach ja, natürlich. Danke.
Aber es kann sein, dass Toulouse an die Europaliga nicht teilnehmen darf, weil man hat den gleichen Eigentümer wie das AC Mailand. Und wenn man nicht so trickreich ist wie Red Bull, wenn du weißt, was ich meine, dann würde der Sechste der Liga 1 reinrutschen, nämlich die großartige Alex Monaco. Leider ohne Alex Nübel, der die Leiche nicht verlängert wurde. Und Toulouse ist halt eine Mannschaft seit dem Pokalsieg, der nur noch seine Spiele verliert. Der Trainer wurde gerade rausgeschmissen, obwohl man als Aufsteiger eine solide Saison beschritten hatte, nie mit dem Abschiedskampf zu tun hatte und wie gesagt, die Coupe de France gewonnen hat. Und die sind schon, glaube ich, fünf oder sechs Stammspieler verkauft worden. Also ich hoffe ganz ehrlich für den französischen Fußball, dass Monaco noch reinrutscht, auch wenn es keine Garantie gibt. Aber was dann Toulouse mit einer komplett neuen Mannschaft, mit einem Trainer, also der Co-Trainer von Montagnier, kommt jetzt in Spanien, der ein Data-Spezialist ist. Und man weiß, dass Toulouse seine Spiele verpflichtet nur durch Data. Nach Data, nach Profile. Das ist schon einzigartig in Frankreich, aber es sorgt auch immer wieder für Unruhe im Verein. Da gibt es zu viele Dissonanzen. Da ist man gespannt, sollte Toulouse tatsächlich an der Gruppenphase der Europa League teilnehmen. Dann habe ich schon meine Befürchtung, dass die Toulousanen nicht so gut hinkriegen wie Norm zum Beispiel, der am allerletzten Spiel, da werden wir gleich ansprechen, den Klassenhandel geschafft hat, aber sich korrekt verkauft hat in der Europa League, 2. seiner Gruppe hinter Freiburg gewesen und gegen Juventus durchgeschehen und sich dabei alles andere als blamiert hatte. Was Lille und Rennes anbelangt, Rennes hat einen starken letzten Saisondrittel gezeigt, obwohl man eigentlich dachte, diese Mannschaft sich nicht für den Europapokal qualifizieren, aber man sieht, dass sich die Mannschaft immer mehr steigert. Man hat einen der reichsten Männer Frankreichs an der Markt mit François-Pignol seit Jahren, aber er will nicht wirklich investieren wie die Kataris oder die Saudis. Er bleibt da sehr bescheiden, aber wenn es darauf ankommt, dann steht er schon zu Stelle und kann die Mannschaft schon einen kleinen finanziellen Impuls geben. Diese Mannschaft hat sich völlig zu reich für die Europa League qualifiziert und hätte die Saison noch 4-5 Spiele gedauert, dann wäre sie noch sehr abgefangen gewesen, weil Rhein in einen Lauf gekommen ist, mit einer sehr attraktiven Spielweise, auch dort sehr viel Euphorie herrscht, dass auch Rhein in der Lage ist, in der Europa League sich gut zu verkaufen und wenn man sich gezielt verstärkt, dann halte ich schon für möglich, dass Rhein in der Champions League kommt, in einem Jahr, denn durch den neuen Modus werden die ersten drei der Qualifizierung der Viertelmütze dann in der Rallye. Und bei Rhein spricht auch dafür, dass der Top-Stürmer Martin Terrier neun Monate lang ausfügt in des Kreuzbandrisses und das war auch eine Erklärung, warum Rhein im Winter schon in einem sportlichen Loch reinfiel, von dem man sich erholen konnte und auch daher bei Rhein eine gewisse Kontinuität auf der Trainerbank was in Frankreich alles andere leider als üblich ist. Und zuletzt Lille. Ja, da herrscht Riesenfrustration, weil Lille hat vielleicht den schlimmsten Fußballer gezeigt mit Paulo von Zecca als Trainer, der wirklich sein Stempel aufdrücken konnte und er eine gute Arbeit geleistet hat. Aber Lille hat zu wenig aus seinen Chancen reingemacht. Die Mannschaft, die am meisten ineffizient war in der Liga, sodass man nur ein Anführungszeichen Fünfter wurde. Da war natürlich mehr drin vom Spielerpotenzial her, vom spielerischen Potenzial auch. Du hast auch schon an Torn David angesprochen, der Kanadier, der auch heiß und worm ist, der wieder seine 20 Tore oder mehr erzielt hat, wie schon in den letzten Jahren. Die Frage ist, was macht Paulo von Zecca? Wenn er wieder gehen sollte, er wird auch von Olympique Marseille und einige italienische Vereine umworben, dann muss die Leibnick bei Null wieder anfangen. Das wäre natürlich wieder bitter, aber typisch für einen Verein aus der Liga, der nicht ganz oben mitspielt. Aber vom rein spielerischen war es wirklich begeisternd, was die Lilleur gezeigt hat, nur mit der Schwäche, nicht genug effizient gewesen zu sein, was bei den Fans wirklich für große Frustration sorgt.
Nachvollziehbar, vor allem, wenn man sich die jüngere Vergangenheit von Lille anguckt. Dann lasst uns kurz noch auf den Abstiegskampf blicken. Uli in der Premier League, da hätte es das Potenzial gegeben zum großen Upset. Leicester hat am letzten Spieltag noch gewonnen. Aber weil Everton auch gewonnen hat, haben sie sich gerade noch gerettet. Also Leicester, Leeds und Southampton müssen jetzt runter. Und Everton, über die wir so viel gesprochen haben, die konnten sich noch retten. Was ist zum Abstiegskampf zu sagen?
Also Southampton, glaube ich, haben wir schon gemacht. Deswegen lassen wir die mal außen vor. Leeds hat sich leider gerade in den letzten Wochen selber zersetzt. Es gibt so eine schöne Grafik. Die kürzesten Amtszeiten von Premier League-Trainern. Ever. Und in dieser Saison sind zwei Trainer von Leeds damit drin. Javi Gracia und dann Sam Allardyce, der einfach nur gekommen ist, um Geld zu kassieren, de facto einen Punkt geholt hat, 11 Gegentore kassiert hat und eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts gebracht hat. Das ist insofern schade, weil es ist nicht so lange her, dass Marcelo Bielsa noch da war und wir wussten, in welche Richtung das geht. Und jetzt haben die so viel Panik gekriegt hinten raus, dass sie ihren Director of Football entlassen haben. Ein absolut fähiger Mann. Dass sie zum zweiten Mal völlig unvermittelt den Trainer entlassen haben und auch davor schon komplett falsch entschieden haben. Jesse Marsch zu holen. Das war das eine, das habe ich damals schon nicht für so ganz richtig gehalten. Ihn zu behalten auch nicht. Dann aber ihn nochmal aufgrund eines Ergebnisses gegen Liverpool über die WM hinaus machen zu lassen. Dann haben sie ihn nochmal komplett unterstützt im Januar-Transferfenster. Also das ist eine absolute Jesse-Marsch-Truppe, die da stand. Und um ihn dann aber zu entlassen, wenn, dann musst du das mit ihm durchziehen bis zum Saisonende oder einen Trainer holen, der es ähnlich bedient. Sie haben dann die Quasi-Kert gemacht und haben Ravig Razia geholt und dann haben sie Final-Kert gemacht von Bielsa auf Sam Allardyce und haben einfach gesagt, okay, komm, wir hatten einen der innovativsten Fußballlehrer, der es gibt und dann holen wir Sam Allardyce. Und damit es auch wirklich richtig kracht. Also kurzum, das ist keine Verschwörung oder so gegen Lietz. Das ist eigene Dummheit und das ist absolut fehlende Klasse im Team unterm Strich oder weiß ich nicht, das Know-how, diese Truppe zu benutzen. Das war einfach von A bis Z mit großem Anlauf. Irgendwann war es dann fast klar, dass sich das so entwickeln würde. Und bei Leicester ist natürlich, also auch da kann man das schon erklären. In West ist lange ausgeblieben von den Besitzern. Also das ist ja eigentlich das Seltsame. Bei Lietz erzählt man die Geschichte von Besitzern, die völlig den Verstand verloren haben. Muss ich vielleicht noch dazu anfügen. Andrea Radriziani ist der Besitzer, der Leeds übernommen hatte, nach Cellino. Das war eine Katastrophenzeit. Und der hat dann Leeds so peu à peu wieder aufgebaut und ist jetzt aber dabei, zu verkaufen. Und diese Sache schwebt jetzt seit über einem Jahr drüber, dass 49ers Enterprises aus den USA, schon wieder USA, den Verein übernehmen wollen und auch wohl schon ganz schön was zu melden haben, obwohl sie Minority Shareholders sind. Aber Radriziani hat sich halt nicht mehr großartig dafür interessiert, ist in der Woche des Abstiegs einfach mal schnell zu Sampdoria gejattet nach Genoa und hat mal überlegt, wie er den Verein dann wieder aufpöppeln kann. Das sind natürlich auch verheerende Zeichen. Das ist bei Leicester ganz, ganz anders. Die Besitzer sind total beliebt und absolut nah dran an der Mannschaft. Und der Verein ist denen alles wert. Das Problem ist, die sind in Tourismus tätig und seit Corona hat deren Business ganz schön zerfetzt. Das heißt, die waren gar nicht mehr unbedingt in der Lage, großartig mit reinzusteuern, obwohl sie wussten, dass der Kader verwahrloste Züge hat. Und nichts dessen, was ich mir gewünscht hätte im Winter, geht ins Risiko, weil jetzt ist es teurer geworden. Der Abstieg kostet sie viel, viel mehr Geld. Das hätten sie noch ein, zwei Spieler geholt. Brendan Rodgers hat die Saison begonnen. Das war... Ich bin ein großer Fan von ihm. Je mehr ich aber darüber höre und lese, muss ich auch sagen, hat er große Fehler begangen. Es war ja mal seine große Stärke zu kommunizieren. Und er hat irgendwann begonnen, dass er die Mannschaft öffentlich so sehr kritisiert oder teilweise auch angreift, dass die nicht mehr bei ihm waren. Jetzt kann man sagen, vielleicht haben die etwas lange an Brendan Rodgers festgehalten, was ich grundsätzlich erstmal gut fand, weil als Dean Smith kam, war das gar nicht so schlecht. Der hat alles auf eine Karte gesetzt, hat die zweite Mannschaft gebracht, mit einem Stürmer sozusagen, wollte nur einen Punkt haben im vorletzten Spiel, damit der Sieg im letzten reicht, wenn es bei Everton nicht gereicht hätte. Er wäre beinahe aufgegangen. Der hat halt nicht ganz den Kader gehabt für ein grandioses Umschaltspiel, wie es zum Beispiel Roy Hodgson bei Crystal Palace hatte. Und auch dann irgendwie mit einer kleineren Ansage, sie haben auch schon ihren Weg verloren, haben auch ein bisschen die Nerven verloren da. Die haben ja Jahr für Jahr so gehandhabt bei Leicester, normalerweise ist gesagt, ein Leistungsträger darf gehen und dann holen wir wieder nach und dann passt das alles. Und so können wir nach und nach diesen Kader zwar verändern, weil wir es müssen, wir sind halt nicht ganz oben mit dabei. Und da haben sie irgendwann auch die Nerven verloren, haben dann Spieler behalten, die sie hätten gehen lassen müssen, haben fatales Verletzungsblech dazu gehabt. Also im Grunde kommt dann alles dazu, was halt dazukommen muss. Es ist trotzdem natürlich fast beispiellos der Abstieg vom Überraschungsmeister und auch der erste, der aus der Premier League absteigt. Tut mir leid, ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie sie es ehrlich gesagt auffangen können. Der Cimbi-Chip würde mich gar nicht überwundern, wenn die jetzt komplett einkrachen.
Und Everton hat sich gerettet. Grandios.
Also Everton spielt das HSV-Spiel jetzt sehr lange. Und irgendwann, glaube ich, würde das auch schiefgehen.
Acht Punkte aus den letzten fünf Spielen waren es am Ende.
Ja, am Ende war es wieder eine Shawn-Dej-Masterclass. Und wie schon auch im Vorjahr, wenn es drauf ankam, haben sie dann doch noch einmal ein Ergebnis geholt. Oder in dem Fall jetzt zweimal. Das 5-1 gegen Brighton ist wahrscheinlich am Bank Call der Mande das entscheidende Ergebnis gewesen für die, dass alle gesagt haben, okay, ja, wenn wir die 5-1 weghauen, dann können wir es wirklich schaffen. Aber seit Jahren mit einem dermaßen schlecht aufgestellten Kader, mit Transfers, vor allen Dingen auf der Zugangsseite, wo man sich denkt, was genau, was macht ihr da? Also als Beispiel sei rausgegriffen, Neil Mopé ist das Team, das mit Abstand die meisten Flanken geschlagen hat. Also sie wurden vom großen taktischen Genie Frank Lampard gecoacht vorher und holen dann einen 1, dass ich jetzt nichts falsch sage, glaube 78-Stürmer, der vieles kann, aber nicht Kopfball spielen. Ich habe das nicht so ganz verstanden. Also es ist dermaßen abhängiges Team von Dominik Herbert-Luin. Der ist halt aber immer verletzt und das weiß man jetzt auch seit Jahren, dass es ihm so ist. Es wird jetzt an der Zeit, vielleicht auch, dass der Besitzer, da ist es wieder auch die Geschichte, Fahrt Moschiria überhaupt keinen Bock mehr, hat am Anfang alles reingebuttert, weil er mit den ganz Großen konkurrieren wollte, hat einfach die Namen verpflichtet sozusagen, hat dann ganz viele Vertragsleichen hinterlassen und hat überhaupt gar keine Lust mehr auf die ganze Sache. Möchte, wie man hört, wohl Hände ringend verkaufen muss er auch, weil die sind ja auch beim Financial Fairplay auf dem Kicker. Das heißt, wenn die den endlich losbekämen, vielleicht ändert sich dann was, aber auch hinter den Kulissen. Das Machtkampf ohne Ende, da sind ganz hässliche Dinge am Laufen, ganz unverstellbare Entlassungen und... Also, völlig HSV. Und irgendwann geht's schief. Eigentlich hätte es in dieser Saison schon schiefgehen müssen, aber irgendwann wird es krachend scheitern.
Heieiei, was ist aus Everton nur geworden? Dann schauen wir noch kurz auf den Abstiegskampf in der Ligue 1. Da hat sich tatsächlich am letzten Spieltag noch was getan. Orzey verliert zu Hause gegen Lens mit 1 zu 3. Und Nort bringt irgendwie in 1 zu 0 Zustand gegen Orzey, die ja schon ganz lange abgestiegen sind. Le Cannery haben sich also retten können, Alexis.
Die Mannschaft war so in einem schlechten Zustand. Man darf nicht vergessen, diese bittere Pleite im Pokalfinal gegen Toulouse. Und dann hat man ein Spiel nach dem anderen verloren, den Trainer auszuschmissen, Anton Gombore vielleicht zu spät. Ist ja so trotz, das hat es doch noch gereicht mit einem Reißprogramm, der doch relativ günstig war. Wie du sagst, der Heimspiel gegen Angers, schon längst abgestiegen, da musste der Sieg her im Derby. Und dann hat man das Nüttigste gemacht. Aber trotzdem müssen da die Lehren gezogen werden für die kommende Saison, weil man will wieder nicht da unten stehen. Nord auch einer der Traditionsvereine Frankreichs, mehrfach Meister geworden in der Vergangenheit. Auch da mit einem großen Fan-Potenzial. Trotzdem tut es mir auch leid für Ossetia, auch für Giroud, die Legende. Er ist auch wie vor Torpfitt mit 86 Jahren, der aber vor zehn Tagen leiden musste mit seinem Ex-Verein oder dem Verein seines Lebens. Weil man nur ein Jahr wieder in der Liga 1 war, jetzt wieder in der zweiten Liga. Gute Entscheidung gestern, dass der Trainer bleiben darf, weil er schon für eine gewisse Aufbruchsstimmung gesorgt hat in der Rückrunde. Und darauf kann man wieder bauen. Denn ich denke nicht, dass die drei anderen Abstiegen, Mannschaften, die abgestiegen sind mit Angers, Ajax, Jons 3, da wieder sofort im Auffliegskampf dabei sein werden. Wir haben so viele Probleme. Und deswegen, Ossère könnte wieder schnell aufsteigen. Und nicht vergessen, dass wir die letzten vier sind abgestiegen, weil wir in der kommenden Spielzeit nur noch 18 statt 20 League-A-Vereine haben. Und dafür sind ja Blue-Off und Metz aufgestiegen.
Ja, genau. Das wird dann in der nächsten Saison mal ganz anders werden in der League A. Mal gucken, ob wir dann... Diese Saison war die WM das große Thema bei allen Ligen. Nächste Saison wird bei der League A dann der kleinere Spielkalender, der kürzere Spielkalender vielleicht ein Thema werden. Wir werden es sehen. Damit haben wir so ein bisschen die Tabellenkonstellation abgehandelt und haben jetzt nur noch so ein paar Erinnerungsfetzen, Anekdoten fast schon, möchte ich sagen, die ich gerne von euch noch abfragen würde. Und zwar als erstes so skurrile Geschichten dieser Saison, die euch vielleicht im Erinnerung geblieben sind oder die vielleicht auch was aussagen über den Verlauf dieser Saison. Uli, ich hab das Gefühl, dass wir schon viele Skurrilitäten gestreift haben. Wir reden ja auch mal besonders viel über Besitzer, wenn wir über die Premier League sprechen. Aber gibt's was, wo du sagst, das werd ich mir wahrscheinlich auch noch ein paar Jahren merken?
Es gab einiges, aber ich muss jetzt mal mich kurz raffen, damit ich das hinbekomme. Für mich ist die Saison so geteilt in Vor- und Nachher-WM, aber das gehört ja alles dazu. Also, ich hab's schon mal ganz kurz angesprochen, deswegen in aller Kürze, diese ganze Ronaldo-Nummer. Der schnelle Absturz eines scheinbar Musterprofis. Ist für mich fast beispiellos, das werd ich so schnell nicht vergessen. Die ganze Chelsea-Storyline ist von A bis Z kompletter Wahnsinn mit Tuchel-Entlastung. Vorher gab's noch, falls ihr euch daran erinnert, diesen Handschlag von Conte und Tuchel. Das war in der Saison.
Da hab ich neulich dran gedacht, ja, stimmt.
Und das ist irgendwie auch so ein Bild, das wird ja für immer ein Meme bleiben, den man einfach so unter einen Fußballpost drunter postet, wenn einem nichts mehr einfällt. Das war auch völlig verstörend und dann das Tuchel entlassen wird. Dass Frank Lampert noch mal zurückkommt, ist auch völlig Banane einfach zu Chelsea. Und dann gab's aber noch solche Sachen wie beispielsweise Konters Pressekonferenz, kurz bevor er entlassen worden ist. Ich war damals unterwegs bei irgendeinem Spiel und habe dann nur die ersten zitierten Kacheln gesehen, so Zitat-Kacheln. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, nee, sowas kann man nicht sagen als Fußballtrainer auf einer Pressekonferenz. Und dann kam noch einer und dann habe ich gedacht, ja, okay, jetzt ist mir klar, so was sagt niemand. Bis ich das Interview gesehen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, das hat einfach alles verbrannt in einem Interview. Und das Gleiche gab es dann nochmal bei Sam Allardyce, der wirklich auf der Antrittspk von Leeds sagt so, ja, Jürgen Klopp, Pep Guardiola, alles gut, aber glaubt jemand mehr vom Fußball weiß als ich? Da muss ich ja auch laut lachen, ehrlich gesagt. Und dann gab es noch ein paar Ergebnisse, die mich einfach haben schmunzen lassen. So ein 7-0 von Liverpool über United. Also wir dachten, die sind legit sozusagen, auch ganz am Anfang der Saison als United gegen Brighton völlig untergeht, wo ich damals meinen Bruder angerufen habe, gesagt habe, siehst du es, siehst du es, siehst du es. Und das sind jetzt wahrscheinlich so die ersten Dinge, die mir in den Sinn kommen von einer schon aber denkwürdigen Saison, das muss man schon sagen. Also da ist schon außergewöhnlich viel passiert. Bank Holiday, Monday war auch so ein Tag. England-Feiertag bei uns, ein ganz normaler Arbeitstag. Und da ging das erste Spiel schon um 16 Uhr los. Das ging schon, weiß nicht, 5.0 aus oder so. Dann kam mein 5.1 von Everton gegen Brighton und ich habe zu Marcel Meiner gar noch gesagt, du setzt jetzt noch einen drauf, so zum Spaß. Und dann wird das ein 5.3. Also auch ein total abstruser Tag, den ich sehr genossen habe. Aber ja, das sind wahrscheinlich so die Dinge, die jetzt so als erstes reinsprudeln.
Es war wirklich eine lange Saison in der Premier League, aber auch in der Liga sind ja Skurrilitäten passiert. Alexi, was kommt dir in den Sinn?
Natürlich muss man über BAP Saint-Germain sprechen, denn das war wieder eine Hollywood-Saison vor drei. Also da kann man sich bei Bayern München dahinter stecken. Es gibt noch Schlimmeres. Nämlich, was in der Kabine ist, kommt alles raus. In München gibt es wohl einen Malwurf, bei PSG gibt es mal Würfe ohne Ende. Es begann halt alles so toll bei PSG. Dieses 7-1 in Lille zu Beginn der Saison, glaube ich am 3. oder 4. Spieltag, Tor von Mwapena 11 Sekunden. Da dachte man, der PSG wird schon im Februar Meister und endlich haben sie es kapiert. Auch in der Champions League wird es wirklich gut aussehen. Und dann hat sich die Mannschaft Schritt für Schritt, sage ich mal, nicht weiterentwickelt, sondern wurde immer schlechter. Und man hat schon das Gefühl, dass die drei außerirdischen Mwapena Messi sich für die WM fit halten wollten. Und alles, was danach kam, war eigentlich völlig wurscht für die zwei Mwapena und Messi. Und wie die PSG-Mannschaft aufgetreten ist, 2023 mit drei Niederlagen in Folge, dann hast du diese 2-3 gegen Lille, und dann macht Messi in der 8. oder 99. Minute das 4-3 nach einem Traum-Freischuss vielleicht der schönste Moment für ihn in seinen zwei Jahren in der Hauptstadt, aber ansonsten kam da zu wenig. Und immer wieder die Unruhe rund um Galtier auch, der bei jeder zweiten Pressekonferenz einen kapitalen Kommunikationsfehler machte. Das war schon immer wieder peinlich, auf diesem Niveau solche Fehler zu machen. Er dachte, der. Wichtige. Dann sieht es nur nach. Man hat das Gefühl, dass der Zuschauer oder der Fan ihn da nicht trifft. Nichtsdestotrotz, was macht der Zuschauer hier? Bei dem Spiel an der Seitenlinie. Der Liga-Verband hat an diesem Montag entschieden, Spiel verloren für Bordeaux. Mets steigt direkt auf. Bordeaux wird in der 2. Saison der Ligue 2 spielen, wenn nicht in der 3. Liga. Denn da muss noch die Lizenz erlaubt werden. Das sieht auch finanziell düster aus bei Girondin. Und mit einem Punkt weniger will man die Saison starten bei Girondin. Und Rodes darf drin bleiben. Und der Leidträngende heißt Anzi, der zwar sein Spiel verloren hat, aber eigentlich sollte man, wenn man klug ist, nicht das Spiel wiederholen von Bordeaux und Rodes und dann einfach die Liga anstatt mit 18 und 19. Vereinen beginnen. Wird aber nicht so sein, auch wenn Anzi mit aller Macht versucht gerade nicht abzusteigen, bzw. den Verein, den Verband zu überzeugen, dass man wie gesagt Anzi nochmal integriert in der kommenden Spielzeit, weil man völlig zu unrecht absteigt und auf den grünen Teppich sozusagen, weil man der Leidträngende ist von diesen Vorkommnissen aus dem Spiel Bordeaux und Rodes.
Ja, da habe ich das Gefühl, da werden wir in der nächsten Saison nochmal drüber sprechen, wie das mit der Lizenz von Jérôme Dorn Bordeaux weiterging, auch so ein Verein. Aber gut, das gibt es ja immer wieder, dass eben die Vereine, die man von früher noch kennt, die einen großen Namen haben, dass die abstürzen und man sich die Frage stellt, wie geht es da jetzt weiter? Ich meine, Everton knabbert ja auch an diesem Status, dass wir da in der Zukunft mal drüber sprechen werden. Dann lasst uns noch kurz auf Spieler und Trainer blicken, und zwar jetzt nicht auf Pep Guardiola und Kylian Mbappé, sondern mich würde interessieren, welche Spieler und Trainer gibt es denn, Uli, du darfst mal vorlegen, die in der Zukunft noch von sich reden machen werden, die man aber jetzt vielleicht noch nicht auf dem Radar hat. Also so ein bisschen die Ansagen Heroes. Du hast ja schon mit Evan Ferguson, ganz Brighton, genannt.
Also Evan Ferguson ist, glaube ich, derjenige, wir sprechen jetzt wirklich von einem totalen Rookie, den in der Vorhersaison niemand kannte, der plötzlich reinkam und ganz viele Leute auch gesagt haben, ja, weiß ich nicht, so nach dem ersten Einsatz. Und auch bei uns im Podcast ist da trefflich darüber gestritten worden, nicht nur im Podcast, sondern auch darüber hinaus mit einem Scout von einem Premier League-Verein, der auch zunächst gesagt hat, ah, da liegt es falsch. Ich sagte, nee, guck hin. Schau nicht nur die erste Viertelstunde, sondern schau mal hin. Und irgendwann hat er geschrieben, I see, der Typ wird irgendwann mal 100 Millionen kosten. Und den lege ich euch wirklich nur nahe. Also es ist auch so erstaunlich. Zum Beispiel hier in Deutschland, ich mache es jetzt mal ganz einfach. Bayern München sucht einen Stürmer. Go for it. Der würde jetzt schon, der würde reichen. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Der wäre jetzt schon gut genug. Und der Typ wird eines Tages der absolute Weltklasse sein. Also es sei denn, er verletzt sich. Ansonsten kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen. Alles, was ich höre, ist der zwischen den Augen optimal. Das heißt, ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwas passieren wird. Das ist schon jemand, der großen Spaß macht, Romeo Lavia vielleicht noch zu nennen. Einer der wenigen Lichtblicke bei Southampton, der echt gezeigt hat, dass er so ein All-Action-Defensiver Mittelfeldspieler sein kann. Guardiola überlegt wohl auch schon, den zurückzuholen zu Manchester City, weil er ihm sehr gut gefallen hat. Der hat großen Spaß gemacht. Dann, ich weiß nicht, ob das zulässig ist, aber William Salibar, den wird Alexi auch noch ganz gut kennen. Wahrscheinlich wird der jetzt sagen, ja komm, erzähl mir was Neues, weil der war bei Sontetien schon ganz nett im letztes Jahr. Aber auf dem Niveau so einen Unterschied zu machen. Und ich behaupte, das wäre der gesund gewesen im Saisonfinale. Wäre es zumindest enger geworden, pro Arsenal und nicht so sehr für City. Das sagt ja schon alles. Das ist das Beste, was die Innenverteidiger hergeben können in ganz Europa. Das ist Rio Ferdinand nur mit noch mehr spielerischem Vermögen. Also es ist der Prototyp für das, was man in Zukunft brauchen wird. Ich habe mich total verliebt in den Spieler. Deswegen sei der, wenn das zulässig ist, auch genannt worden. Den haben wahrscheinlich alle auf dem Schirm. Das ist jetzt nichts total Neues. Der hat sich in der Saison schon weit genug in den Vordergrund gespielt, aber völlig zu Recht, weil einfach Wahnsinn.
Ach, ist das schön, die Schwärme zu hören. In Zukunft mache ich nur noch solche Segmente. Alexis, wen kannst du ergänzen? Da wird er gerade in der Ligue 1, ich meine, wir haben ja hier mit Salibard auch schon wieder mal wieder einen französischen Innenverteidiger. Huch, wo kommt das denn auf einmal her, der viel kann. Also da bin ich jetzt besonders gespannt, Alexis, wer fliegt jetzt noch unter dem Radar? Und in einem Jahr werden wir alle sagen, damals im Rasen vom Katz Alexis Menuge schon gesagt, der wird groß.
Ja, es gibt sicherlich einige in der 2. Liga, aber bleiben wir erstmal in der Ligue 1. Opendo habe ich schon erwähnt, der Belgier, der vielleicht Longstor noch verlassen wird. Aber es gibt auch den jungen Bradley Barcola bei Olympique Lyon, ein ähnlicher Fußballer, der aus der eigenen Akademie kommt, wie viele früher auch bei OL. Ich hätte mir gewünscht, bei PSG einige zu nennen, aber da ist es schwierig. Da lässt man die jungen Talente sehr schnell gehen. Aber ich denke, ein junger Hugo Ekitike, der Stürmer, der aus Ranskomm kam vor einem Jahr und der sich nicht zuschätzen konnte, würde aber in der Bundesliga sehr gut reinpassen, weil er sehr stark in der Luft ist, sehr athletisch und alle Voraussetzungen hätte, um in der Bundesliga definitiv Fuß zu fassen. Dann hätten wir natürlich auch Jonathan David, nach wie vor kein großer Name in Deutschland, aber auch er würde sehr gut passen als reiner Strafraumspieler, sehr kompletter Spieler, immer brandgefährlich, auch sicherer Elfmeterschütze gibt es auch nicht überall, um nur den zu nennen. Und was halt imponieren wollte in dieser Saison, der Bundesliga-Torschüstenkönig hatte glaube ich nur 17 oder 16 Tore, was schon unüblich ist. In der Liga hatten wir sechs Spieler über 20 Tore, unter anderem fast der Oldie, Alexandre Lacazette, der sich bei Arsenal in den fünf Jahren nicht wirklich zusetzen konnte, aber immerhin 28 Treffer erzielt hat in dieser Saison, aber er wird auch nicht mehr bei einem ganz großen Verein wechseln, dafür ist er einfach zu alt. Aber auch er gilt schon als einer der großen Gewinner dieser Saison, auch wenn sein Verein noch einmal versagt hat und sich erneut nicht für einen europäischen Wettbewerb qualifizieren konnte.
Ja, aber die Torjäger, es sind nicht nur die Innenverteidiger, die aus Frankreich kommen und wer weiß, wenn du jetzt noch alles aufgezählt hättest, wenn ich dir erlaubt hätte, auch noch über die Ligue 2 zu gehen, das ist ja einfach der französische Nachwuchs. Es ist der Hammer. Alexis, wer ist denn dann vielleicht ein Trainer, der noch in Zukunft von sich Reden machen wird?
Frans Elzab ist schon erwähnt von Lans, weil er relativ jung ist und sehr modern im Fußball spielen lässt. Er ist auch sehr eloquent, bei Pressekonferenzen wirklich sehr bodenständig, bescheiden auftritt, aber auch ein gewisser Humor hat. Also wirklich ein Traum eigentlich, wenn man sich die anderen Trainer in der Liga anschaut, wie Clément, wie Tudor bei Marseille, Clément bei Monaco, Digard bei Nice, die alle entlassen wurden seit den letzten zwei Wochen oder von sich aus gehen mussten. Von circa ist bekannt, aber in den unteren Regionen haben wir schon erwähnt, bei Rasenfunk in dieser Saison, Uli Stihl von Reims, der die Mannschaft richtig stabilisiert hat, der auch einen modernen Fußball prägt, der einen sehr interessanten Weg hinter sich hat und der jetzt langfristig verlängert hat. Bei Reims, also ein Auge auf ihn, muss man unbedingt werfen. Und als Engländer und Belgier hat er sicherlich auch irgendwann eine Zurung der Premier League. Ich glaube schon, dass er da Fuß fassen würde. Und das ist auch sein Traum. Also da sollte man schon ein Auge haben in den nächsten Jahren. Und natürlich auch Le Brice von Lorian, der womöglich nach Nizza wechselt. Auch er hat sich aufmerksam auf sich gemacht, weil er einen sehr attraktiven Fußball spielen lassen hat. Nicht zu vergessen, das hat man auch erwähnt, bei Rasenfunk im Herbst. Da war Lorian hinter PSG, zweiter in der Tabelle nach einem ersten Saisontrittel. Natürlich war es schwer, bei diesem Spielermaterial da oben zu bleiben. Aber auch er ist heiß und warm, auch sehr jung. Regisseur Le Brice, auch wichtig, sich anzumerken. Es wird nochmal von ihm geredet sein und zwar positiv.
Meine Güte, das ist immer so eine ganze Klopapierrolle voll mit Namen. Das große Pargament wird ausgerollt. Wie ist es denn in der Premier League, Uli?
Der bald 76 Jahre alte Roy Hodgson könnte mal einer werden. Wenn irgendjemand mal ganz was Neues aufbauen will. Im Ernst, ich glaube, in der Premier League sind die aller, aller meisten Trainer, absolute Welttrainer und damit auch in aller Munde. Aber es gab auch in der Saison ein, zwei. Bei einem bin ich immer so leicht geschwankt. Steve Cooper, der am Ende jetzt einen Klassenhalt geschafft hat mit 600 neuen Spielern. Das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so leicht, die alle zu integrieren. Der hat einen recht abwartenden Ball spielen lassen, absolut und ausschließlich Konter basiert, aber es hat funktioniert. Daher, der muss irgendwas haben, der Typ. Ich bin immer noch nicht so, wenn ich mir die Systeme jetzt anschaue, die er hat laufen lassen, dann bin ich immer noch, manchmal denke ich, ja, okay, ich verstehe es ja auf der einen Seite und dann würde ich mir wieder denken, also in der Premier League nur mit Low Block zu spielen, finde ich ein bisschen wenig, sondern ich hätte hier und da gerne etwas mehr Druck drauf, aber jetzt schauen wir mal, was er in der zweiten Saison macht. Er ist dringeblieben, er hat sie erst mal eh schon stabilisiert hochgebracht, dann dringeblieben und er hat auch bislang bei seinen anderen Stellen, an denen er gearbeitet hat, einfach ausgezeichnete Ergebnisse geholt. Und der, der mir aber meistens ins Auge gestochen ist von den Unbekannten, ist Gary O'Neill von Bournemouth, der auch in der Saison erst übernommen hat für Parker nach einem 9-0 von Bournemouth gegen Liverpool und eine Pressekonferenz. Ja, die hätten wir auch zu den Kulisse hätten nennen können. Aber O'Neill ist genau das Gegenteil. Der hat so, also auch grundsätzlich spielt er auch einen relativ abgeschlossenen Mittelblock, aber mit Abstand, talentfreiesten Truppe der ganzen Liga. Und das meine ich genauso, also nicht untalentiert, sondern da ist nicht viel. Auch wenn sie jetzt eine Übernahme bekommen haben, ein bisschen, ein paar Talente dazu, haben man die entkönnen, da ist nicht viel. Und der hat die recht souverän am Ende drin gehalten. Und der hat in seinem Spiel das Beste vereint, also sozusagen einerseits defensive und dann aber in verschiedenen Ebenen Pressing-Sequenzen eingebaut, die selbst Premier-Leagisten große Probleme bereitet haben. Und das finde ich total erstaunlich. Also der scheint ein großes Auge zu haben für die richtige Situation, hat dann auch teilweise in der Saison mal wieder gesagt, nee, komm, wir parken den Bus, wenn es sein musste, um dann aber auch wieder offensiv zu werden. Also es scheint mir jemand zu sein, der ein unheimlich gutes Gespür hat, hat für mich einen totalen Unterschied gemacht für Bornmars in der Saison. Und deshalb muss ich den einfach unbedingt nennen. Ich bin jetzt auch gespannt, wie es weitergeht bei dem. Das ist keiner, der einen wahnsinnigen Lebenslauf im Moment hat, sodass man jetzt denken würde, ja, das war ja immer klar, dass der auf jeden Fall Trainer wird. Es gibt viele Leute aus seinem damaligen Umfeld, alte Trainer, die sagen, der war immer sehr gewissenhaft und war immer jemand, der gut zugehört hat und der einfach in Tegah war, im Schädel was hatte, aber nie so ein, dass du schon wusstest, naja, gut, der wird irgendwann mal mit dem Laptop rumlaufen und parallel noch schon 18 Daten geschluckt haben, sondern ich schaue es mir jetzt einfach an. Vielleicht ist das so ein Gespürtyp, aber dem traue ich ganz schön was zu.
Und dann kommt ja nächste Saison, den ich so gerne in der Bundesliga gesehen hätte. Jeder, der mit Thomas Bräuchmar drei Sätze gesprochen hat über seine Karriere, der hört heraus, was für ein Trainer das ist.
Also das, von dem erwarte ich große Dinge, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist so einer dieser Charakterköpfe, wenn euch mal langweilig ist, wenn man ein größeres, gesetztes Interview mit dem kriegt. Ich höre den wahnsinnig gerne reden. Das ist so jemand, der haut nicht so Motivationsbinzen raus, sondern das ist so ein wirklich, der hat das Gewinnen verinnerlicht. Und ich liebe das, wenn so fast arrogante Aussagen kommen im Sinne von, ne, wir sind hier um zu gewinnen. Und ich glaube, das hat er den Spielern gut beigebracht. Er hat so einen Guardiola-Disciple auch, einer von denen. Und wenn der dann noch so eine eigene Spielerkarriere hat und eh schon immer so ein echten Typ war, auf den freue ich mich auch sehr.
Mit Bernie, dann wird das sein. Und Post-It-Chocolate bei Tottenham. Einer von vielen, die mal wieder versuchen, Tottenham irgendwie wieder auf rechts gedreht zu bekommen. Denn irgendwie ist da alles upside down. Aber gut, das werden wir alles in der nächsten Saison sprechen. Letzte Frage an euch beide. Alexis, du darfst beginnen. Welche Erinnerungen wirst du an diese Saison haben? Also gibt es irgendein Bild oder etwas, das passiert ist, oder etwas, das du vielleicht auch erlebt hast, wo du sagst, das wird bleiben, auch in fünf Jahren, wenn ich dich noch mal frage, wie war denn das damals, 22, 23? Was wird deine Antwort sein?
Muss das die Liga sein oder kann das auch die Champions League sein?
Das kann auch die Champions League sein.
Weil diese Grätsche von de Ligt bei dem, was war das, ein Rückpass, nicht ein Schuss von Vitinha. Ein Rückspiel in München bei St. Null Null. Wenn es da reingeht, vielleicht, Uli wird mich natürlich gleich belächeln, aber vielleicht wäre es in Istanbul gewesen. Man weiß es ja nicht mehr im Fußball. Und bei Bayern wäre Nagelsmann auch früher entlassen. Und Bayern wäre doch im April schon Meister geworden. Das sind alles Szenen, aber die Grätsche war einfach so geil. Aber auf der anderen Seite Paris schon wieder dermaßen harmlos. Und das ganze Verhalten, halt Messi, Kopf unten, Bapé war auch an dem Tag das Spiel des Jahres. Die zwei Vereine, über die ich am meisten berichte, sind auch die zwei größten Hollywoods Europas. Das ist natürlich mein Glück. Aber wenn ich mir wünschen würde, dass es sportlich vor dem Europa ein bisschen erfolgreicher wieder sein würden. Aber es gibt jeden Tag etwas zu berichten, vor allem bei PSG. Jeden Tag, das ist unfassbar. Und wie gesagt, diese Grätsche war schon ein Symbol, weil es war schon sehr spektakulär an sich. Das Spiel war nicht besonders spektakulär. Das Hinspiel im Prinzenpark auch nicht. Aber das Gefühl, wenn beide Mannschaften oder Vereine ganz anders sind von der Philosophie, es gibt sehr, sehr viele gemeinsame Punkte von der Entwicklung her auf der Trainerbank, im Kader, die Kadergestaltung, die Ergebnisse. Wenn man wirklich zu PSG kommen sollte in den nächsten Tagen, dann hätte man schon die gleichen Trainerinnen und Trainer bei Bayern und PSG in den letzten drei Jahren gehabt. Mit Tuchel dazu. Also ein Bild war, wie gesagt, diese Grätsche von de Ligt. Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, da war aus französischer Sicht die Ergebnisse im Oberpokal sehr enttäuschend, sodass man ruhig aufpassen muss in der kommenden Saison, dass nicht die Hinterlande an Frankreich vorbeizieht. Was eigentlich gut für Holland wäre, aber für Frankreich schon eine Schande. Aber das wäre verdient, weil man nicht so gut arbeitet, weil man nur zweimal den Europapokal gewann in 65 Jahren. Das ist schon schlecht für ein Land, das eigentlich den Europapokal ursprünglich gegründet hat, wenn man sich die Lage so zusammen entfassen sollte.
Ja, schöner Schluss. Vor allem bei dem ganzen Talent, das man hat. Es ist ja eigentlich komisch, dass natürlich schwärmen die irgendwann aus und verteilen sich über Europa. Aber man hat sie ja zumindest in der ersten, der zweiten und vielleicht ja manchmal sogar auch noch der dritten Saison. Da sollte ja eigentlich was drin sein. Uli, was wird deine Erinnerung an diese Saison sein? Vielleicht jenseits noch vom Champions League Finale? Ich glaube, das wird für immer bleiben.
Jetzt wollte ich das so schön in die Kamera halten und gar nichts mehr sagen. Ich muss mal schnell überlegen, weil das überschattet natürlich jetzt ganz viele gerade in meinem Kopf an dem Zeitpunkt, an dem wir aufnehmen, ist das so allgegenwärtig und ansonsten nicht mehr so viel. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sonst nennen könnte. Gerade jetzt auch mit Premier League Bezug. Wahrscheinlich ist das so was wie... Irgendwie habe ich auch Lutentown noch im Kopf, das Aufstiegsfinale, weil das so eine nette Geschichte ist. Abseits von all den Multi-Club-Konstruktionen und staatsgeführten Premier League-Vereinen oder generell Vereinen ist das so eine schöne Geschichte.
Wie lange hast du noch mal mit dem Podcaster von denen gesprochen oder dem Journalisten zur Vorbereitung?
Ich glaube drei Stunden oder so. Aber dann noch mal im Nachklapp auch noch mal eine Stunde. Dann haben die mir auch noch ganz nett in so einen Twitter-Space eingeladen, weil sie total gefreut haben, dass jemand aus Deutschland mitfiebert. Ich glaube, die können das immer noch alle gar nicht fassen, was da passiert ist. Also die ersten Bilder, wenn dann eine Guardiola-Truppe reinläuft in dieses Stadion, das wird sensationell. Das wird einfach, das wird total, also wie du hast verfeuert, hat Leso angesprochen, so ungefähr wird es sein, dass man sich denkt, nachkommt. Kann eigentlich gar nicht sein, das wird total lustig. Das habe ich auch noch irgendwie automatisch im Kopf. Und dann mag es wahrscheinlich sowas sein wie, weiß ich nicht, ein einzelnes Spiel, so ein 7-0 von Liverpool gegen United, das mir sofort im Kopf schießt oder das 9-0 von Liverpool damals. Mehr kriege ich aber gerade noch nicht hin.
Ja gut, aber das, was bei dir das Champions-League-Finale ist, wo du eben das Badge, deine Akkreditierung, in die Kamera gehalten hast, das ist ja völlig klar. Und looten aber auch noch sehr schöne Geschichte, gerade eben, wenn man weiß, wie du dich da reingekniet hast in der Vorbereitung und welche Freude, ich glaube, nicht nur du, sondern auch Sebastian Kneisel an diesem Spiel hatten.
Ja, der hat ja sogar noch auf Sendung ausgerufen, dass wir, also den kann ich jetzt auch noch mal hier sagen, falls ihr mit dazu wollt, dann, das ist ja Kneisels Problem, nicht meins. Reisegruppe Uli hat das genannt, weil das sein zweiter Vorname ist, Ulrich. Und er hat einfach mal so im spontanen Rausch gesagt, wer mitfliegen will, wir machen das. Wir gehen zusammen nach Luten und wir besuchen ein Premier League Spiel. Das ist absolut unmöglich, aber...
Viel Erfolg beim Kartenkriegen, Herr Kneisel.
Ich habe schon tatsächlich den Tickets-Manager, den habe ich schon in der Kurzwahl. Ich bin so weit, aber so viele, die sich gemeldet haben, wird es schwierig. Aber lass es uns doch verdreifachen, damit er ein richtiges Problem kriegt, Herr Kneisel.
Also, sagt noch mal rechtzeitig vorher Bescheid, dann komme ich auch mit. Dann gibt es Liga Tour on Tour. Das würde ja genau passen. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, sehr herzlich und ich danke auch allen anderen Gästen, die hier waren. Das ist das letzte Mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass die Liga Tour so als eigenes Format erscheint im Schlusskonferenz-Feed in dem Fall. Diesen Schlusskonferenz-Feed wird es bald nicht mehr geben. Ich habe es am Anfang der Sendung gesagt, jetzt noch mal die Erinnerung, wir stellen unsere Feeds um und dann gibt es einen Gesamt-Feed Liga Tour. Ich habe mich in dieses Wortspiel verliebt. Es wird bleiben, da werden dann auch die 2. Männer-Bundesliga und andere Ligen noch drunter gefasst werden und natürlich auch dieser Rückblick, den wir hier hatten. Ganz herzlichen Dank euch beide, schön, dass ihr mal wieder mit dabei wart. Danke, Alexi. Danke euch auch. Und in Abwesenheit natürlich auch David Fragier de Pau-Lewa und Michael Postel, die noch mit dabei waren. Und natürlich auch Jogi Hebel. Und wir grüßen ganz herzlich. Hendrik Buch heißt er, der es in dieser Saison nicht geschafft hat. Aber wir hoffen für die Zukunft. Bis bald, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wieder im Rasenfunk. Bitte unterstützt uns, bleibt uns treu. Macht's gut. Das war die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.